hello everyone welcome to the May 2023
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll those
of you who are regular listeners will
remember that last month you know we do
the AMA episodes every month we do
episodes every week but once a month
once yeah once a month it's an AMA
episode and so the April 2023 episode we
began with a story about the March 2023
episode the March 20 23 episode I
started off by talking about the fact
that it had been really hot in Baltimore
over the summer and I sort of jokingly
or at least not very seriously connected
that to climate change and how it
affects people's visceral reaction to
these scientific findings and people
didn't like that so that particular
podcast episode was much higher audience
numbers on YouTube of all places regular
podcasters listeners didn't care but on
YouTube somehow people were funneled to
listen to that I guessed it was because
of me mentioning climate change because
it got terrible reviews that episode you
know got more dislikes than the typical
episode and also there's a bunch of
weird people in the comments complaining
about climate change and scientists so
to do the experiment last month I also
talked about climate change in the intro
wondering whether YouTube's algorithms
would somehow find it once again
mostly for fun like I'm not actually
going to be doing this as a regular
thing to try to get more engagement
anyway the experiment was a complete
failure actually that's not true the
experiment wasn't a failure experiments
are only a failure when you don't get an
answer when you don't learn what is
going on but the hypothesis that by
talking about climate change in the
intro I would drive engagement that was
falsified by the experiment no more than
the average number of viewers slash
listeners Etc
um so I don't know I don't understand
what makes people uh find the podcast on
YouTube for that matter
I don't really understand what makes
people find the podcast at all uh I wish
I did you know I would like to bring the
word of the podcast to more people I I
think I'm talking about it all the time
and everyone knows that I have a podcast
and yet I'm still constantly running
into people who in my mind would be very
natural audience members for the podcast
who who don't know that I have a podcast
who've never heard of it so I don't know
how to get the word out there I gotta
gotta be a little bit more systematic or
scientific about that these kinds of
things
um otherwise that's it I have no great
words of wisdom for the intro here we
have lots of questions to get to I will
just offer the standard reminder that
these AMA episodes are sponsored by the
listeners on patreon so you can go to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll and you can
support mindscape with a dollar or two
per episode it's fine if you don't but
it's nice if you do and then you get to
be part of the community you get ad-free
versions at the podcast and you get to
ask these questions that we are here
answering on the amas too many of them
for me to answer all of them but I try
to answer ones where I have something
interesting to say and with that let's
go
[Music]
thank you
our first question is from Rue Phillips
I'm actually continuing the climate
change thread here so I picked Rue's
question to go first just to keep that
notion in your head so Roo asks the
following I am trying to understand the
science of climate change the potential
harm and what can be done about it to do
this I read books watch the news read
summaries of climate reports Etc so when
I come across a book like unsettled by
Stephen coonan I am left wondering is
climate change politicized and
sensationalized enough that it will
never be realistically understood Enough
by the layperson voter I would summarize
the main takeaway of coonan's book as a
need for us to be more careful about
what the science says and in particular
with what uncertainty and not broadcast
headlines that are far from what the
data really say how do we get voters
better informed on climate change
without ulterior motives
well there's a lot going on here in this
question I will try to answer it in as
level headed away as I can
um there is a very broad consensus by a
very wide spectrum of experts in climate
change people who actually study the
atmosphere and the Earth for a living
that number one the climate is changing
very rapidly number two it is mostly due
to human activities one way or another
and number three the consequences of
this will be disastrous
there's also a large number of people
who are highly resourced and motivated
who don't want us to do anything about
it or not anything that might for
example hurt the pocketbooks of the oil
industry uh the fossil fuel industry
more generally so you have scientists
who of course scientists don't always
agree with each other of course there
are uncertainties of course it's very
difficult to model the climate climate
science is endlessly fascinating and
complicated the climate is a complex
system it's very very hard to say
exactly what's going to happen it's
going to be very hard to make accurate
predictions but the data are crystal
clear and in fact over the last 20 years
whenever climate scientists have gotten
together to make projections about what
will be happening to the global climate
in the next 20 years they have
underestimated very very consistently
what the size of the effects are
actually going to be the climate has
been changing noticeably more rapidly
than climate scientists worried about so
yes there is uncertainty yes there is
unsettlement but no there is not a
feeling that somehow it's being
sensationalized and alarmized so that
people are more worried than they should
be people are less worried than they
should be is the truth of the matter and
I'm not sure how it's possible to miss
that conclusion if one does actually
read summaries of climate reports and
look very carefully at scientific work
by experts in the field Stephen coonan
is someone who I know of he used to be
Caltech professor before my time he's a
physicist and he's known not not so much
for contributions to physics but for
administrative things you know he was
the Provost of Caltech he worked for
government for a while he also worked
for the petroleum industry for a while
he was Chief scientist at British
Petroleum and so he's not only not a
climate scientist he is exactly the kind
of person who is a mouthpiece for making
people feel that climate change is less
of a worry than it really is I just did
two minutes of Googling before doing the
AMA I found the following quote by kunin
the impact today of human activity
appears to be comparable to the
intrinsic natural variability of the
climate system itself
not to put too technical of a spin on
this but that is complete horseshit that
is very very wrong as any actual climate
scientist will tell you so yes I
absolutely think that we should be
careful about what the science says we
should be particular with uncertainty
and not broadcast headlines that are far
from the data what the data really say
and also not pay too much attention to
people with obvious ulterior motives
like Stephen coonan who is not a climate
scientist once again science is hard you
know we're not going to get the once and
for all perfect answer it's not that
someone knows exactly what the climate's
going to be doing over the course of the
next 50 years and as long as we listen
to that one person we'll be fine
scientists disagree with each other they
have difficulty modeling very complex
systems so we do the best we can the
answer to uncertainty and unsettledness
is not to say well you know don't be E2
alarmist don't move too quickly we are
taking a sledgehammer to the planet on
which we live and it's always possible
that the sledgehammer will actually
miraculously fix something that we had
broken in the planet you never know you
could say the same thing about taking a
sledgehammer to your computer there's a
chance it will fix it but that's not the
way to bet the way to bet what the
climate is we are obviously doing
terrible things to it and we should move
as quickly as possible to stop doing
those things
Colleen Edwards says within the last two
years I've become really interested in
quantum mechanics and physics good for
you Colleen those are good things to be
interested in I'm 37 and in a sales
career I love but have a basic math and
science background so the abstract
equations and info associated with
quantum physics could get very tricky or
impossible to follow for me that's okay
though I like a challenge I've been
reading listening to many of your books
and books by other fellow physicists in
addition to youtubing and Googling the
crap out of every piece of info I don't
understand in an effort to really give
it an honest try because it is truly
fascinating stuff do you have any
techniques or suggestions for helping
the average Jane get a firm
understanding of quantum physics in her
spare time
uh I mean this is both a super important
question and a super difficult question
because I feel I can say things but
they're nothing other than you know
platitudes that's like the obvious
things there's no I don't have any
secrets in other words okay I don't have
any like oh if you do this suddenly you
will understand quantum mechanics really
well I think that the only thing I will
say is that there are levels of
understanding and it's important to
appreciate that so if you read a popular
book on quantum mechanics like my book
for example something deeply hidden you
will
be challenged because the ideas and the
concepts are very very hard but even if
you really understand it even if it's
very very clear and you really feel
you're getting something you're never
getting the full thing because you don't
have the equations okay that's why I'm
currently working on this series of
books the biggest ideas in the universe
where I do the equations I mean I should
be finishing book two right now but I'm
pretty close to get I'm getting there
don't worry
um and I also did YouTube videos with
the same title the biggest ideas in the
universe where you can find some of the
equations there and then you can be very
serious you can look at textbooks or you
can go to online courses from places
like Stanford MIT and elsewhere where
they really do the details of quantum
mechanics and
there's no right or wrong here there's
no correct level of understanding
um different people learn in different
ways some people like books some people
like videos some people like talking it
through if you really want to understand
it you have to do problem sets right to
solve some equations and play around you
know uh playing and creativity and
experimentation are crucial to really
taking some of these difficult ideas and
making them embedded in your bones but
most people you know they don't have the
time for that much less uh the
inclination so you know you will never
be satisfied then but that's okay is my
message you will never think oh okay now
I perfectly understand quantum mechanics
I hope you never feel that I hope no one
in the world feels that when I wrote a
op-ed for the New York Times a few years
ago after publishing something deeply
hidden and I said physicists still don't
understand quantum mechanics and what is
even worse they don't even try almost
all of my physics colleagues who emailed
me about that loved it I said oh yes
this is great I'm glad you're speaking
up about this there was only one person
I'm not going to say who it was one
person did email to say well I
understand quantum mechanics I don't see
what the problem is most people get that
all of these things are very very
difficult to master so the platitude I
would offer is enjoy the journey it's
not about the destination find which
modalities work for you whether it's
YouTube or books or just talking to
physicists on Twitter or whatever and
enjoy understanding a little bit better
every day one percent better every day
is uh the motto of Tyrese Maxi who is
one of my favorite Sixers basketball
players if you can understand quantum
mechanics one percent better every day
you'll be on the right track
Mike Brock says as a social species it
seems that through language and
Technology humans have become part of an
emerging information processing
superstructure with the internet Ai and
complex societal systems as additional
rungs above us
in the past individual choices had a
more significant impact on society's
trajectory but now it appears that these
emergent systems are the dominant forces
shaping our Collective Destiny as an
advocate of poetic naturalism how do you
perceive this potentially darker view of
the diminishing importance of the self
and the sense that Humanity's age may
already be over with society's
coordination increasingly Beyond human
control as a follow-up point in question
I worry that all this has Grave
implications for the stability of
democracy given your research into the
physics of democracy and your personal
appropriation for
you wrote appropriation Mike but maybe
you mean appreciation for Democratic
systems of government that I share what
do you think of these concerns
you know I'm not sure what answer you're
anticipating here but my answer is I
completely share these concerns I think
these are very very important concerns
so to rephrase it a little bit just to
make sure that I understand
um the world is changing technology is
changing the world the world is
shrinking right we're more in contact
with people around the world global
events can affect us and affect us
quickly in ways maybe they couldn't 200
years ago and also as a result of that
because you can sort of influence and
know about larger and larger swaths of
the world it is possible for Nations and
international systems to become bigger
and bigger
there are inefficiencies in the economy
or whatever that go away once everyone
is connected to everyone else that's the
good news but the bad news is there's
also systems of control that become much
much larger than individual human beings
and I think that the worry about
democracy is very much on point because
a typical person let's say in the United
States where I live and I'm most
familiar with
a typical individual doesn't think they
have much say in the federal government
right probably not even in the state
government there's this idea that
there's this giant system that has an
enormous impact on our lives and we have
very little say in it even if it's a
democracy you're still one out of
hundreds of millions of people and when
you look at what politicians are doing
what government is doing Etc it is very
easy to get the impression that they're
not centrally focused on the concerns
that are up under uppermost in your own
mind
couple that with the fact that I mean
there's a lot of things to couple it
with two things let me just mention two
things one is that uh because the world
is changing you can have situations
where your family was uh involved in
some industry or some job for
generations and now that job's
disappearing so you can't do it anymore
there's disruption maybe you lived in
the same house for a long time but
there's some reason why now you have to
move so there's disruption there so
there's this feeling that the
expectations that we have of what life
is supposed to be like are declining
over time we don't have the ability to
just sort of stay the course there's no
like happy medium where we just do the
right thing act like good citizens and
everything is fine it's become more
effort to find a niche where we can
individually be successful
that's one consideration and the other
consideration is that the elites if I
can put it that way uh people who are
either captains of industry or what have
you or people who are in the government
Etc
are getting better and better at
manipulating the levers of control right
uh it's you know if you have a local
coffee shop and it's really just that
one coffee shop it's not a member of
Starbucks or whatever
um and I'm trying to say this in the
least weird scary conspiratorial way but
if there's literally a local store that
is owned by people who work in the store
you go into it something is wrong you
can complain and you're complaining to
the owner of the store who has a vested
interest in making it better if you go
into a franchise of a huge chain and you
complain you're just given a hard time
to some poor person who works there
you're not talking to the owners to the
real people who have control over what
is going on so once again it is hard to
have an impact in many institutions that
are very very important for your
individual life what to do about this
I'm not sure so I don't know uh what to
say about Mike's question here
um I think that there is a problem I
think there's a there's a problem that
has been understudied as far as I know
just dealing with the scale of modern
institutions versus the concerns of the
individual and I worry that that
mismatch that has grown up in the recent
decades does have deleterious effects on
Democracy especially people's
interest in preserving democracy why
preserve democracy if your vote isn't
changing anything right I think that's a
very very real worry
and we see it by the way
in the rise of populism and romantic
nationalists because people just get
frustrated and so rather than voting for
someone who is a sensible person who
will Implement good policies they vote
for people who they think will shake
things up people who are not beholden to
the usual ways of doing things or
whatever and you know most ways of
shaking things up make things worse
rather than better A lot of them appeal
to our less good instincts within
ourselves so these are all problematic
things we have to worry about
Walter E Miller says in discussions
about anti-matter the first
consideration is usually why did all the
anti-matter from The Big Bang disappear
leaving us in a matter-only universe if
that's true why is it that antimatter
pops up so often in our matter only
Universe during radioactive decay one
example is Neutron Decay that includes
an anti-neutrino rather than being an
interloper is antimatter actually an
embedded fixture of our so-called
matter-only Universe well if you listen
to scientists talk about the asymmetry
of matter and antimatter there's
different levels of carefulness that
they will sometimes tell you including
myself here I'm not I'm not excluding
myself from this very very mild critique
sometimes they will say there is more
matter than antimatter why is that the
truth is we don't know if there is more
matter than anti-matter
because many of the particles the in
fact the vast majority of particles that
make up the known universe are either
photons which are sort of their own
antibiotic so they're even or neutrinos
neutrinos are very low mass particles
that were created in abundance in the
early universe and we have very little
if any idea whether that neutrino
background in cosmology is mostly
neutrinos or anti-neutrinos we don't
even know it's just very very hard to
measure we can't detect it directly so
if we're being a little more careful we
say that what really clearly exists in
the universe is a baryon asymmetry
baryons are the heavy strongly
interacting particles like protons and
neutrons and there we know that in our
observable universe there are far more
protons and neutrons than antiprotons
and anti-neutrons and that by itself is
a puzzle so the scientific challenge is
variogenesis what created the asymmetry
between baryons and antibareons maybe
there is a compensating asymmetry in the
neutrino background that gives us more
anti-neutrinos than neutrinos or maybe
not we just don't know but you know
antimatter is not anything weird and uh
scary and difficult to make like you say
Walter antimatter is produced all the
time okay the the Large Hadron Collider
at CERN collides two protons together
but the tevitron at fermilab collided
protons with antiprotons the reason why
the LIC doesn't do that is because
antiprotons are much harder to make and
the LHC is trying to have a large
Luminosity as many collisions as they
can possibly get so it's just easier to
make protons and protons rather than
depend on your supply of antiprotons but
anyway the point is that antimatter is
by no means itself mysterious why there
are more baryons protons and neutrons
than antiberions that is mysterious
Rob and Jess asked a fact that gets
thrown around a lot in pop science books
is that light because of its speed
doesn't experience time but if a photon
doesn't experience time if they use it
if the universe is Frozen for it then
what happens to it when time passes and
the universe changes surely the photon
then must experience some type of time
because the universe it exists in has
changed and time is change well number
one I wouldn't say time has changed I
don't think it's quite that simple
that's like a little motto that has some
validity to it but not 100 validity but
more importantly uh I'm developing you
know this is a question I get many times
I've talked about it many times uh I'm
developing a slightly new take on this
question because this is a question
where the equations are 100 clear right
I mean there's no actual issue in
writing down what is happening for
photons the correct thing to say about a
photon as long as photon is moving
freely through the universe not bumping
into anything else then it's elapsed
proper time as we Define it in general
relativity it's elapsed proper time zero
that is true for any massless particle
now for you and me
what the proper time is is the amount of
time we experience the amount of time
that is read on our wrist watches okay
any clock we bring with us measures the
amount of proper time we experience for
a photon that number is zero but as you
say the photon is moving through the
universe which is changing what is going
on I think that there's a major problem
that people have
because they want to imagine what it
must be like to be a photon what would
it be like literally Einstein imagine
this what would it be like if we were
moving at the speed of light but the
thing is if you're moving at the speed
of light that well the thing is you're
not moving at the speed of light and you
can't okay individual massless particles
can move at the speed of light as soon
as you get more than one particle
together in a system it will generally
have a mass it will generally have a
non-zero uh energy density in its rest
frame and therefore there must be a rest
frame and therefore it's not moving at
the speed of light you can have two
photons moving the speed of light but
they're not connected to each other by a
string or anything they're just moving
you know and they're separate
trajectories so the idea of experiencing
time
just as in relevant to a photon it
doesn't have any memories it doesn't
have any experiences okay and and this
is you might think that this is kind of
a
beside the point kind of um observation
but I think it's very relevant to
clearing up our internal worries about
what is going on here you know an
electron doesn't experience time either
because an electron doesn't have a clock
that it's carrying around it does have a
proper time that we can measure but it
doesn't feel anything it doesn't see
what's going on in the universe I think
that's the fundamental issue we have
this issue that if we were moving close
to the speed of light or at the speed of
light what would we see and experience
about the universe around us but there
are no things that move at the speed of
light that at any experiences whatsoever
so just say the true thing would be my
advice the true thing is that the proper
time elapsed on a photon trajectory is
zero and there's no clocks moving at the
speed of light so it's not a worry for
what clocks think or what changes or
anything like that it is both true that
the photon exists at different moments
of time is measured in the universe and
that zero proper time elapses along its
trajectory
Astro Nobel says will the quantum
computer help to determine which of the
10 to the 500 possible String Theory
models fits best to the universe we live
in
short answer is probably not at least I
don't see any special way that's going
to happen the problem is we don't have
anything like a list or even a
characterization of those 10 to the 500
possible String Theory models for one
thing the the number 10 to the 500 is
wildly hand wavy some people think it's
much smaller than that some people think
it's much bigger than that some people
think the whole conversation is just
kind of nonsense okay 10 to the 500 came
up I think probably in this paper by
Rafael buso previous mindscape guest and
Joseph polczynski where they first
started thinking about what we now call
the string theory landscape different
ways to wrap brains and fluxes around
extra Dimensions to give us different
low energy laws of physics they
estimated a number or something like
that but it's just an estimate we don't
have a list
we don't have a definitive way or an
algorithm for constructing all of these
things and saying what they are so
there's no list to search through for a
quantum computer okay maybe the quantum
computer can help us solve the equations
that will produce such a list
um but then it would have to do a lot of
work to predict what a particular
configuration of extra Dimensions
implied for low energy laws of physics
it seems impractical to me even for a
pretty big quantum computer but I've
been surprised before
Dutch cheese says do you understand what
is meant by reincarnation I've been
listening to some podcasts about
Buddha's philosophy but there seems to
be no self everything is interdependent
there is just experience there seems
nothing personal left to reincarnate I
don't understand this paradox so I'm
probably the worst person to ask about
this question because I think that there
is no such thing as reincarnation
therefore I don't need to know what is
meant by it
um you know Buddhist philosophy is an
interesting thing there's a lot of good
stuff going on there but you know the
same thing is true for other
philosophies there's a lot of good stuff
going on there too what is not going on
in Buddha's philosophy or
Native American philosophy or Anglo
philosophy or German philosophy or
anywhere else from centuries ago is a
modern understanding of physics
especially quantum mechanics okay they
may use some words in any one of those
schools of thought that kind of roughly
corresponds almost by coincidence to an
idea in modern physics but that was not
Based on data and the Schrodinger
equation or quantum entanglement or
anything like that okay so from the
point of view of modern physics there is
stuff and the stuff is described by the
Schrodinger equation and the rules of
quantum mechanics and that stuff comes
together under the right circumstances
to make a person as a higher level
emergent phenomenon and so you are made
out of the stuff that you are made out
of there's no extra stuff other than the
physical stuff that makes you up and so
I've given talks and and written things
blog posts anyway about life after death
according to Modern physics you could
Google them it's pretty easy to find
and I'm very clear about the fact that
when you die the process that is you
ends the atoms that make up your body
are changed very little if at all upon
the moment of death but the process
changes a lot like snuffing out a candle
okay the candle doesn't change that much
when you snuff it out but the flame
stops and gradually after you die the
arrangement of atoms in your body that
gave you who you are your memories your
personalities your your ways of living
in the world all that decays all that
ceases there ceases to be connections
between neurons and so forth so there's
no sense in modern physics in which
anything like the traditional notion of
reincarnation has anything any
plausibility whatsoever so I would say
that and let your favorite philosopher
or Theologian deal with it as they will
says what happens when anti-matter falls
into a black hole are there antimatter
black holes if so what happens when an
antimatter black hole collides with a
regular black hole so you can make a
black hole out of antimatter but well if
you had enough antimatter you could
hypothetically do it you never will have
that much antimatter but you could if
you did though it would not be an
antimatter black hole all black holes
are described by their Mass the total
energy in other words their electrical
charge and their spin their angular
momentum so that's all that's all the
information that tells you what your
black hole is in particular the
information about whether or not it was
made of anti-matter or matter originally
is not included in what characterizes a
real world black hole so
there's no such thing as an anti-matter
black hole there are just black holes
you know you have to think black holes
are not objects like rocks or stars or
around dwarfs or anything they're
regions of space-time black holes are
made of space-time that matter that went
into making the black hole goes behind
the Event Horizon and is now lost to us
so what happens when an antimatter black
hole collides with a regular black hole
is exactly what happens when any other
two black holes Collide you get a bigger
black hole
Johann Falk says I'm trying to make up
my mind about how to treat the risk that
humanity is overrun by artificial
general intelligence within say 50 years
and I find myself in a situation similar
to Pascal's wager or Pascal's mugging a
non-negligible fraction of AI
researchers think that there is at least
a 10 risk of human extinction or
similarly permanent and severe
disempowerment from future AI systems
how do you think that I or people in
general should treat risks like this
well I think you should treat them
cautiously I think the people in general
should be cautious when it comes to AI
but not be alarmist I think there's a
difference between those things
um
I'm not sure what is going through the
minds of a non-negligible fraction of AI
researchers who think there's at least a
10 risk of human extinction after all
these are people who are experts in AI
they're not neces I mean by the way I'm
not even sure they are experts in AI
some people are kind of self-proclaimed
experts in AI even though they've never
written a backward propagation
subroutine for a large language model or
anything like that but anyway
being an expert in AI is very different
than being an expert in human extinction
being an expert in biology and sociology
and economics and ecology and whatever
it might take right so I don't take
these estimates very seriously at all
but that's okay I think that unlike the
climate change situation where we kind
of know what's happening and it is
definitely bad in the AI situation we
should recognize the unknown that is to
say we're doing a new kind of thing
that's the interesting thing the the
interesting thing is not we're doing a
dangerous thing we're doing a new kind
of thing and we should always be
cautious when we do something radically
new like that I always think back to
Martin Reese who was on the podcast and
we were talking about existential risks
from the Large Hadron Collider
and he made a really really good point
he said you know he was testifying
before some parliamentary committee or
whatever and he said
they're absolutely as being a good
scientist right he said look there
absolutely is
a non-zero risk that the Large Hadron
Collider leads to something disastrous
ending the Earth or whatever something
equally bad okay
he said there's also a non-negligible
chance that Large Hadron Collider
creates a Panacea creates free energy
shows us how to you know violate the law
of conservation of energy and gives us
you know removes us from our need for
fossil fuels or anything like that and
makes uh Humanity Awash in abundance
both of these possibilities are very
very very tiny uh one of them could be
literally a million times bigger than
the other and we just don't know so what
do you do you know what how do you
balance these things I don't think that
human beings are very good at balancing
these very small probabilities versus
huge impact kind of events
so therefore rather than you know trying
our best to pretend to calculate a
number
and attach it to the probability of
something very bad going wrong we should
just be cautious right I mean we should
just move slowly we should be careful
about checking what we're doing we
should try to think of all the specific
ways that things could go wrong so I'm
I'm just not interested when people say
I think there's a 10 chance of human
extinction what does that what does that
mean where did that number come from how
do you calculate that if you say here is
a path
for human extinction that gets me much
more interested if this happens and then
this happens and then this happens it
could lead to terrible consequences
that's a useful contribution there when
you say things like that and you had but
you have to be very very specific very
very clear right you can't just say well
it's very powerful it can do things you
need to be much more clear about that
because only then will you enable us to
do something constructive to prevent
that from happening
um I don't think that the call for a
pause in AI research is a very good idea
if only for practical reasons like no
one's going to get everyone in the world
to pause all their research in fact
there was there was for for those of you
who don't know there was an open letter
calling for a six-month pause in AI
research uh and some big names uh signed
it some of those big names are still
going great guns at AI research trying
to out-compete their competitors okay so
it's just practically very very hard to
do I mean it's kind of a symbolic action
that makes you feel good without
actually changing anything I'm much more
interested in figuring out what are the
pathways for AI to actually do bad
things and then try to figure out how to
prevent those Pathways from coming true
Craig Stevens says my understanding is
that one of the first demonstrations of
the superiority of Einstein's theory of
general relativity was that it correctly
predicted the orbit of mercury which
Newton's Theory did not if this is true
what is it about Mercury that makes
Newton's Laws of Motion fail in this
instance while working perfectly well
elsewhere in the solar system I like
this question because I know the answer
to it it's very specific and definite
um two things actually they're both
required one is as as you said in a
parenthesis I didn't read Mercury is
close to the Sun the gravitational field
that mercury is moving in is Just a
Little Bit Stronger
than the gravitational field that Venus
or the Earth or whatever moves in if you
go through the equations there is a
correction to the Newtonian equations of
motion that comes in in general
relativity that comes in more and more
noticeably the closer you get to the sun
very very roughly I don't want to push
this too much but very roughly if you
think of Newtonian gravity as 1 over r
squared right the famous inverse Square
law there's a new contribution in
general relativity that goes as one over
R cubed so an R is large 1 over R cubed
is negligibly small compared to 1 over r
squared but when R gets small then you
begin to notice the other thing that is
equally important is that mercury has an
eccentric orbit okay it's not in a
circle if you had a perfectly circular
orbit or even a very close to Circular
orbit then the amount of procession you
would get is both less and harder to
measure uh so we got lucky with Mercury
I mean we really got lucky when you
think about it it was just the right
distance and just the right eccentricity
to be noticeable by 19th century
astronomers so it was there for Einstein
to make that prediction
says as an author podcaster and
generally someone who makes his voice
heard in public do you ever get
criticisms or negative reactions that
feel distressing and if so how do you
cope with that also to balance the
question what kind of positive feedback
do you most enjoy
I mean yeah I get Negative reactions all
the time
um there's a huge selection effect in
people reacting to things on the
internet
that favors negative reactions right
people like many times whether it's on
Twitter Youtube or blog comments or
whatever
I just look at it and I say like why did
you bother to leave that comment it's
like if like it's it's often not you
know here is a substantive criticism
that I have of you but just like well I
listen to you for an hour and it was
really boring I didn't learn anything
so okay so but why do you listen for an
hour and furthermore why did you feel
like you need to spend extra effort to
go leave a comment that's a little
depressing
um I'm not a confrontational positive
kind of guy I have a confrontation
avoidant kind of guy and it's it's the
single biggest downside of having a
public voice on the internet and
elsewhere is that you constantly get
criticized and uh and also I'm not
blameless myself
um I would I'm working very hard I'm not
very good at it to be more constructive
and less snarky on Twitter and on the
internet more generally
um more productive more pushing positive
agendas of uh constructive ways to live
in the world rather than just making fun
of people I disagree with if you look at
Twitter these days it's I mean or or
ever not just these days but um it's
just so easy to make fun of people
that's what people just do back and
forth all the time and I get it
sometimes
um and I don't like it it affects me I
remember the negative comments or it's
not that I remember them I honestly
couldn't tell you what most of my
negative comments were but they have an
impact in the moment on me that is much
greater than the compensating positive
comment so I do like positive feedback
um but I also like critical feedback
that is actually constructive right like
saying well you did this but maybe you
should say this instead like that's fine
I love that but that is very very rare
in our modern internet
Redmond says Infinity is a mathematical
concept not a number we haven't
encountered infinity and even if we did
we would be unable to measure or count
it why then is it practical important or
even meaningful to describe space time
as infinite in extent as opposed to
immeasurable
well because it might be infinite an
extent I mean this is just how science
works we make hypotheses we compare them
to the data right so that space time is
infinite an extent is a hypothesis
um if you if you simplify your life and
say that space time is either infinite
or finite
that matters right you have different
theoretical ways of dealing with that I
mean let's let's think about time in
particular because it's a little bit
more Vivid there if you just use the
ordinary equations that we know and love
of quantum mechanics time doesn't end
there's no beginning okay in the usual
Schrodinger equation starting from any
wave function I can evolve it forward or
backward an infinite amount so my theory
like I didn't develop the Schrodinger
equation I didn't develop it at all but
Mr Schrodinger didn't develop it to
understand the Big Bang he was thinking
about Atomic Spectra and things like
that and but what we do in science is we
take the theories that work and we
extend them Beyond where we develop them
and we say is it still working we don't
assume that it does work but we presume
that it is applicable and then we test
it we go and look for whether or not the
predictions that are made using that
method make sense so if you think that
the Universe had a beginning if you
think the time is not infinite or
likewise if it is not infinite to the
Future because it has an ending
tell me where that shows up in your
equations okay you need to work to
explain how that appears and maybe it
does
but you're trying to understand the
world at a deep level
and if that is made easier by
postulating a space-time that is
infinite in extent then good then you
should do that then you should put High
Credence on that being true by the way
parenthetically we don't have such high
Credence right now I mean people
describe space time as possibly being
infinite but honestly we don't know we
can't see it we don't know enough to say
right now so you shouldn't be too
confident about those things
Jeremy Merrill says nuclear
proliferation is much more common in the
last 70 years than States giving up
nuclear weapons since having nuclear
weapons confers benefits to those who
possess them mainly not being attacked
by other countries and the technology
needed to develop nuclear weapons
becomes more accessible over time
doesn't this trend lead inevitably
toward nuclear war at some point in the
future it's hard for me to see how it
could not well
not inevitably no I mean that I think
that putting the word inevitably in
there weakens your argument immeasurably
because inevitably means there's a
probability of one maybe the probability
is 0.999 but someone's going to nitpick
you on the word inevitably the relevant
question is does it make nuclear war
more and more likely to the point where
it becomes probable or in any case
something we should really worry about
if nuclear war is only a five percent
chance of happening I think that's
something we should very very much worry
about and there I think the answer is
yes I mean I absolutely am extremely
worried about nuclear proliferation
there's more things that can go wrong
when more people have access to
incredibly destructive Technologies
right I'm not sure what to do about it I
mean ultimately what to do about it is
to make the world a better place uh
spread democracy and prosperity through
the world so that no one wants to start
a nuclear war I mean the United States
is not going to attack Canada with
nuclear weapons because there's no
benefit to doing that we want to make
every country in the world like that and
then you know I'd be I can imagine a
future where countries do voluntarily
give up nuclear weapons right now it
seems very unlikely for exactly the
reason you say it gives you leverage it
gives you a voice at the table if you
have nuclear weapons you can't be
ignored okay so one of the reasons why a
lot of people give for either supporting
Russia or at least not supporting
Ukraine in their recent war of Russia
invading Ukraine is that Russia has
nuclear weapons we don't want to get
them too angry so they use the nuclear
weapons therefore we should mollify them
in some way it's it's kind of analogous
to the you know LHC AI existential risk
thing because are you sure that by
mollifying Russia or any other nuclear
power you're not making nuclear war more
likely rather than less likely this is
very difficult to no it would be much
better if we could just decrease the
number of countries that had nuclear
weapons that's beyond my pay grade to
see actually how to do that but I do
think let's say this
we don't talk about nuclear war these
days nearly as much as we did when I was
growing up right in the 70s and 80s
there were real worries it was the Cold
War and there was real worries we could
actually have a nuclear war and since
the Cold War ended even though there are
still lots of nuclear weapons out there
and lots of countries that have them it
is less high on the list of global
concerns and I think that is a problem I
think that's that's too bad I think we
should worry more about nuclear war via
proliferation than we actually do
shambles says somewhere somewhere over
40 percent of people are now categorized
as neurodivergent in some way that
number is still going to increase as we
understand more in the relevant fields
of study do you feel these labels are
useful as they will likely cover half of
humanity fairly soon or should we be
looking to dispense with them and
reassess what the heck is normal anyway
well I don't have a specific
recommendation for whether or not that
label is useful or we should do
something else but let me talk about
this this General issue because I think
it is actually crucially important
um the way that I see it what's
happening is that in the modern world we
are gaining at the social level not the
individual level more understanding and
more respect for differences between
different kinds of human beings not just
neurodiversion so that's one way of
doing it but gender and sexuality
diversity is another very obvious kind
of thing uh ethnic racial diversity and
you know who belongs in what category
and so forth we're becoming a little bit
more careful and nuanced and hopefully a
little bit more Humane in dealing with
these kinds of questions you know it's
just easier to ignore differences to
categorize people as our people and
everyone else to uh give our people the
rights and take them away from other
people I think that as a society we're
trying to do a little bit better at that
and I think that's good that we're
trying to do a little bit better then as
I'm sure as you're thinking right now
it's not Universal that we're trying to
do better at it some people are trying
to dry us back to the Stone Age but I do
think that you know we're getting a
little bit better and that's a good
thing but it's also hard it's not a
straight line you know I mean people
make jokes about the name that we give
to black people in the United States is
it black people is it colored people is
it African-Americans right uh Negroes
you know what is the right word to use
if we are trying to be as polite and
considerate as possible right even if
your goals uh your intentions are as as
good as they can be it's still not clear
what you should actually do my point is
just that that's okay that's what you
should expect these are hard questions
you shouldn't say well if we don't get
it right immediately then somehow there
was something wrong about the attempt
people will work this out
neurodivergence is something that I'm
very glad that people are recognizing
the existence of it and thinking in a
more careful way about how to deal with
it you know we had the podcast with
Camilla Pang who talks about exactly
this as a neurodivergent person herself
and it's hard right it's not like okay
I'll be polite therefore everything I do
is going to be okay right you need to
actually think about what it means
to uh live in a world where people are
kind of complicated it's easier to live
in a world where people are simple and
those who diverge from the simple
expectations are bad or wrong or you
know should be shunned right that's a
much easier world to live in but it's
not a better world so we're beginning to
learn to deal with this kind of
complexity and Divergence I don't know
what the vocabulary is going to be a
hundred years from now but as long as we
try in good faith and try to respect
each other as much as we can I think
that the process is going to get us to a
better place
John Stout says can you clarify what is
the significance of this Nima arkani
Hamad often begins his Talks by saying
this and letters husken said quote put
every put a bit of information at every
point in space and then your number of
bits will be proportional to the volume
what's so hard about that well what's so
hard about that is you'll wind up
putting so much energy into the region
of space that you create a black hole
and the black hole will be bigger than
the region that you were trying to
populate in the first place with
information so using ideas from black
holes from Hawking and beckenstein and
so forth I think a tuft and I both came
somewhat independently to the conclusion
that you under no circumstances could
ever put more information into a region
of space than its area
area measured in little planking in
pixels and once you say that you begin
to think well maybe there should be some
theory in which the interior volume of a
region should be described by degrees of
freedom to live on the boundary
yeah I mean what the significance of
that is that suskin is just describing
what we call the holographic principle
right the idea that not all points in
space are independent from each other
and it's kind of a basic feature of
gravity once you know there's gravity
once you know there are black holes okay
which is a new thing in general
relativity there's no black holes in the
same sense in Newtonian gravity once you
know that's true
that's kind of a new limit on how much
you can do in any one region of
space-time if you didn't have gravity
and by the way I completely agree with
all this I even wrote a paper on it
saying uh with um ning Bao and ashmeet
Singh we said the Hilbert space of
quantum gravity is finite dimensional
okay it was one of these essay contest
entries and it wasn't a new argument
from us but we tried to like say that
one particular conclusion as clearly and
forcefully as possible and that's a way
of saying that there's a new kind of cut
off on what you can do given to us by
gravity uh sometimes in Quantum field
Theory we talk about an UltraViolet cut
off we say at very very short distances
we don't know what's going on so let's
cut it off let's imagine that our Theory
just does not talk about what's going on
at distances smaller than some
particular length scale and you might
think that only gives you a finite
number of things that can happen but of
course there's arbitrarily large
distances you can talk about so maybe
you want to put an infrared cut off also
you know the size of our observable
universe or whatever
and then you might think if you have a
largest possible scale that you can look
at and the smallest possible scale
there's only a finite number of things
that can happen inside
still wrong because at every point an
infinite number of things can happen not
only can I put one piece of information
at one point that information can be the
number zero or the number one or two or
three and it will eventually in in
physics cost more and more energy to
excite the quantum fields that are doing
that counting and so without gravity you
can do an infinite number of things in
any region of space-time but with
gravity as Lenny says in that quote you
will just create a black hole and if
you're limited to a certain region of
space there's a biggest possible black
hole you can make and really the lesson
of this the holographic principle etc
etc is that information is not
separately distributed at regions of
space
there's something that is non-local
about how the world works at a deep
level in quantum gravity I don't think
we're quite ready to say what exactly
that is what how exactly the
non-locality should be talked about in
quantum gravity but we're getting closer
and closer to it you can look back at
the podcast archives for discussions we
had with Lenny suskin with Rafael Busa
with Neda engelhardt uh and probably
some other people about where this kind
of non-locality comes from and what
we're going to do with it
David Maxwell says my work can sometimes
be about an interesting thing and
sometimes the actual day-to-day work
involves is intellectually satisfying
but it's seldom both
how much of what you do professionally
both in your higher level choices and in
the day-to-day work is for academic
enjoyment and how much is because you're
passionate about a question did you get
into physics because of a sense of
wonder do you stay in it and expand or
refocus the way you do because you enjoy
the intellectual stimulation or because
you want real answers and believe you
can help find them no matter what type
of work is required is it the journey or
the destination
so I'm I'm going slowly in answering
this question because when it started I
I thought it was going to be something
else
I I'm a believer that in almost every
kind of work there are aspects of it
that are interesting and fun and
rewarding and other aspects which are
just tedious if you're a professional
athlete you gotta practice you gotta
work out and exercise if you're doing
general relativity for a living you have
to push some tensors around and it's
never that much fun although general
relativity itself is fascinating being a
an athlete is kind of cool likewise if
you're a musician or a writer or
whatever there are tedious aspects of
what you do they're rewarding aspects of
what you would do but David's question
is not apparently about that it's a more
subtle distinction between the
day-to-day progress being interesting
and worthwhile versus the
final product being rewarding and that
that's a tougher one I think it's to me
it's got to be both you know I would be
very
unsatisfied if the day-to-day
manipulations were interesting and cool
but didn't lead anywhere I'm a believer
that
um one wants to accomplish things in
physics you know I always tell my my
students this by the way this is a
slightly difficult lesson to learn as a
graduate student because when you're a
graduate student you know in theoretical
physics very often when you're an
undergraduate you took courses but you
didn't write papers you didn't do
publishable results in theoretical
physics and now in graduate school you
are
so you're you have new Talent a new
capability capacity you can write
publishable theoretical physics papers
and I know this from my own experience
like you can be so swept up in that that
the very fact that you can write a paper
about something
inspires you to do it I can write to
people about this let's do that rather
than stepping back and saying but wait a
minute I only have a finite number of
heartbeats left in my lifetime am I
writing the most interesting and
important papers that I can possibly
write about as we talked about with Andy
strominger recently that's a trickier
thing to do but so I do think it's
important to aim for things that
give you a destination
but you also of course want the journey
to be interesting also so I don't think
it's any simple answers to this one it
is a good question a subtle one I think
it's one of those questions where you
balance right I mean if you were a
musician and you did nothing but scales
all day long and didn't get to like play
at the end of the day it'll be that
would be tough
um you but you can make the journey a
little bit more interesting I I do think
that the journey in intellectual work is
fun I mean there's nothing more exciting
than just sitting around the coffee
table with fellow
scientists or philosophers or whatever
and being introduced to a new idea a new
way of thinking a new Twist on something
you've been worried about for a long
time
um but then you want to go do something
with it you want to you know go make
something out of it write a paper or
whatever that's also part of what what
we're here to do
Eric dovigi says if I know something
about a system is the fact that I have
knowledge about it part of that system
do I decrease the entropy of a system by
studying it or is that a totally hair
brained notion
so no it's not a totally hair brain
notion I don't think that you change it
by knowing something about it but you
might change the way that you
characterize it in fact this question
you're asking is basically uh exactly
the question that that was asked in a
talk that I saw by Wayne mervold who is
a philosopher of physics and so I like
the question so much that I repeated it
in the question in a talk that I gave
recently on uh the philosophical what is
it the philosophy of quantum
thermodynamics questions or Topics in
the philosophy of quantum thermodynamics
it's a talk that I gave recently it's
online and I quoted Wayne's little
question when the question is the
following
let's say you have in front of you a cup
of coffee with cream in it okay a
standard uh example of entropy and you
look you can sort of macroscopically
characterize where the cream is where
the coffee is and you can doing that
assign an entropy to the system that is
in front of you okay the weird thing
about entropy
is that it there's versions of it that
are related to our knowledge of the
system so Wayne's question is okay now
someone else walks up to you and says oh
I have in my back pocket
a complete list of all the atoms and
molecules in that cup of coffee and
exactly what they're doing right now
perfect information the question is did
the entropy just go down
because you now have in principle maybe
you didn't even look at the list but you
know it's there if you believe you're
the person talking to you you it is
known exactly the micro state of the
system and you know the answer is it
depends what you mean by entropy okay
there's definitions of entropy where you
do not change the entropy At All by
knowing anything about it there's
definitions where it very much is a
characteristic of your knowledge so I I
think that the ant there's a simple and
sadly correct answer in this case it
depends on what you mean it depends what
you're using the notion of entropy for
and it's very operational by the way you
might say well who cares the answer is
if you know the microstate of the system
then you can be Maxwell's demon you can
extract work from A system that is in
thermal equilibrium if you know it's
microstate exactly if you only know it's
macroscopic properties then you can't so
it does matter it really does matter for
physics and what we do for things uh but
I think there's a fairly simple
straightforward way of thinking about
answering this question
Paul torreck says in your mad dog ever
Readiness and paper with ashmeet Singh
you suggest that reality is represented
by a vector in Hilbert space Eddie
keming Chen proposes instead density
Matrix realism the quantum state of the
universe is objective it can be Pure or
impure is there any reason to prefer a
pure State over an impure one for one's
Mad Dog of readinessm so the short
answer is no there's no real reason
um for those of you who don't know
what's going on here in quantum
mechanics as hopefully you've heard me
mention there are not separate wave
functions for different parts of the
universe there's only one wave function
for the universe as a whole when we
think about subsystems of the universe
then if those subsystems are entangled
with the rest of the world they will
generally not be something you call the
wave function of the subsystem
nevertheless there is a way of
characterizing the physical state of
that subsystem if you erase all of your
knowledge that it's entangled with the
rest of the world we say the subsystem
is an mixed state which is defined by a
mathematical thing called the density
Matrix or the density operator
so a mixed state is basically somewhat
analogous but not quite to a probability
distribution over possible wave
functions or ever possible
Quantum States it's a little bit more
subtle than that but that's the basic
idea so the question is
for the universe as a whole should we
think of it in terms of a pure State a
wave function or a density Matrix the
thing is that for the thing about
density matrices is there's no
experimental difference right the whole
point of having a density Matrix
description of a subsystem is that your
predictions for things you might want to
observe about that subsystem are exactly
the same as if you knew it's precise if
there was a precise wave function for it
and you can do what that wave function
was so I'm not sure that it matters that
much but also if you do have a density
Matrix you can always artificially
promote it to a pure State you can just
imagine there's more to the universe and
then you can what's called purify the
density matrix by uh imagining that your
subsystem is entangled with the rest of
the system that you just added to it so
again I just don't see much of a
difference I think it's simpler for me
to talk about a vector in Hilbert space
but if you want to talk about a density
Matrix knock your yourself out be my
guest
Casey Mahone says I took a few art
classes in college and the one school
thought I'd never I could never
understand was minimalism perhaps it's
because I tend to go so far in the other
direction when I create or admire art I
always gravitate toward things that are
full of complexity and detail are you an
appreciator of the minimalist style and
can you help me find it less boring well
I am a pluralist uh in art appreciation
like many other things I do think that
you should appreciate what you
appreciate and both maximalism and
minimalism in their different ways mean
something my own art style favorites
have been evolving I think a little bit
with time uh for a long time I just
regular old abstract art was my favorite
which is in some sense is minimal it's
not you know the level of detail you
find in a great Renaissance master or
something like that uh but Jackson
Pollock or Mark rothko they're not gonna
have a lot of tiny small scale details
but increasingly these days I want some
I'm looking for some sweet spot where
it's kind of abstract it's not really
you know direct representation
photorealistic or anything like that but
there's also some meaning there there's
some extra layers that mean something
that refer to something in the outside
world in some clever way that's my own
personal favorite I think as far as
minimalism is concerned I might be being
unfair here but to me that's the kind of
thing where we need to talk about super
duper minimalism like you know a
background of a single color with like a
little stripe or something like that or
a dot in the middle nothing else
makes sense only in the context of what
is going on in art at the time and in
art history right it's a comment on what
is art what is going on right now and
it's a it's a useful thing I don't want
to denigrate it it's drawing your
attention to certain aspects or certain
questions maybe you weren't paying
attention to and so forth but I wouldn't
want to hang it in my living room okay
or don't even want to spend that much
time looking at it at a museum you can
sort of get the point nod and then move
on so I think it has a place but it's of
the moment it's a little bit less
um I don't want to say of Eternal
interest because nothing is but of super
long lasting interest than some other
styles uh you know I'm I'm old school
and then I want my art to be beautiful
and I want it to be layered enough that
I can appreciate it over and over again
and and see more and more things all the
time
Justin Wolcott says to the best of my
understanding hume's stance on causality
suggests that our belief in cause and
effect is based on experience and habit
not absolute certainty like a philosophy
of science which acknowledges that
theories are supported or disproven by
evidence rather than proven Hume
highlights the limits and uncertainty of
our understanding of causality
hypothetically imagine there was a
laplace's devil a super LaPlace demon
demon who had perfect knowledge of the
wave function of the universe does Humes
stance on causality still apply to them
or can they actually speak of cause and
effect at the fundamental level
well I think there's two things going on
here one is that Hume I'm not an expert
on Hume by any means uh so I'm not gonna
be the one to go to if you want an
exegesis of what Hume actually wrote but
I get the point of what he was trying to
say and it's you have to distinguish
between
kind of metaphysics versus epistemology
right like what is actually going on at
the deepest level versus what we can
know about what's going on at the
deepest level and I take hume's point to
be primarily although not exclusively an
epistemological one it's about what we
can know how we infer things about the
universe we often look at the universe
and we infer cause and effector we infer
continuity Through Time broadly speaking
we infer laws of physics laws of nature
more generally right but what Hume is
saying is that we're not seeing those
causal relationships directly what we
see is stuff this is even if you grant
the possibility that what we're seeing
is not unvarnished okay we just had to
talk with Andy Clark where we talk about
participating and creating a controlled
illusion in our perceptions but forget
about that imagine that you just had un
unmediated access to what's really going
on in the world what you see says Hume
is what's going on in the world now now
and then the next moment and then the
next moment and as we human beings who
attribute some pattern there that we
would like to call a law or a cause and
effect relationship Okay so
that's I I take it that that is his
point and that's going to be true
whatever the form of the actual laws of
physics are whether it's classical or
Quantum whether it's stochastic or
deterministic or whatever so there's an
interesting question to be had why does
this picture of having laws of physics
at all work so well that's a very
interesting question to ask we just had
a workshop here at the natural
philosophy Forum at Johns Hopkins uh
talking about Barry lower's upcoming
book Barry was a recent podcast guest he
has a new book coming out on humanism
about the laws of physics and of course
we had Ned Hall on earlier who also
talked about humanism but as far as
perfect knowledge of the wave function
of the Universe goes I would say almost
the opposite of what you said that is
exactly where you don't want to speak of
cause and effect but this is an entirely
different
question than hume's issue okay and the
reason here is because cause and effect
are macroscopic phenomena it's it's the
it's very much not there's a sort of
simple-minded thing that goes around
that in quantum mechanics there's
fluctuations so there's no causality
forget about all that that's nonsense
okay there are laws of physics the
Schrodinger equation or whatever they
turn out to be that's what matters but
the point I'm making here is not that
there's Randomness therefore no cause
and effect it's that the idea of
speaking the language of cause and
effect doesn't apply in fundamental
physics whether it's deterministic or
not because instead you should speak the
language of the fundamental laws of
physics f equals m a in f equals m a
there's no cause and effect at every
single moment of time there's a force
and there's an acceleration and they're
proportional to each other it's not that
one is causing the other or anything
like that it's that kind of pattern even
when you go to relativity or quantum
mechanics that characterizes the laws
physics speaking the language of cause
and effect only becomes important at a
higher macroscopic level
David Dubrow says what is the
relationship between thermal equilibrium
and black holes if they both represent
regions of space with maximum entropy
well maximum entropy compared to what
under what circumstances uh with what
constraints are all the questions you
have to answer so for example you know
that black holes aren't really regions
of Maximum entropy or systems of Maximum
entry because they Decay into something
else they Decay into Hawking radiation
spreading out in all directions then you
can even calculate the entropy of that
Hawking radiation it is larger than the
than the entropy of the black hole from
which it was made the more accurate
thing to say is that a black hole is the
most entropy that you can fit into one
region of space of fixed given size the
Hawking radiation is spread out over a
much larger distance likewise when you
say a system is in thermal equilibrium
you know compared to what or in in
relationship to what very often you have
some subsystem of the universe that is
more or less isolated but not completely
okay and in fact this is very very
important because you can be in a meta
stable equilibrium you can be in a
situation that looks like equilibrium
that looks like it's in its highest
entropy state but secretly there is
another state that could be in of even
higher entropy there's just no easy way
to get there right so if you imagine a
balloon with helium in it
if you pop the balloon the helium
expands to fill the room you know it
mingles with the air in the room and
that's a higher entropy state
but when it's in the balloon there's
still a higher entropy State take it out
of the balloon and spread it around the
room but it can't because there's a
balloon there okay so just because there
exists a higher entropy State doesn't
mean you naturally evolve to it in the
case of a box of gas that you say is
high entropy or in thermal equilibrium
usually it would be the case that if we
took all that gas and squeezed it into a
black hole it would be even higher
entropy the problem is that there's not
enough gravity to actually make that
happen so it's always maximum entry
compared to what or on what time scale
or Etc you just have to worry about the
footnotes and the details in these
questions
Tom Kenyon says I was born within 10
days of you and I also have a degree in
physics my question is more related to
the former what is your earliest memory
of a national or world event I often
think I remember the first moon landing
although I'm probably conflating my
actual memories of Apollo 16-17 with
later TV documentaries of Apollo 11.
yes I think that I'm not even going to
give a good answer to this question
because I very much appreciate this last
little bit of what you said
we are terrible at remembering uh past
events vividly uh and our very first
past event I think that if you asked 100
people in the street their first memory
almost none of them would be reliable
that is what I think because we do have
similar events that come later or we
were reminded of what's going on or or
so forth
um I I would not even presume to say
what my actual first memory was I do
remember uh going to the voting booth
with my mom who voted for Richard Nixon
that must have been that couldn't have
been 68 though I would not remember that
if I was just two years old that must
have been 72 so six years old and
probably I have memories even before
that
um I definitely had memories of watching
moon landings but I could not I would
definitely not tell you that it was
Apollo 11. that doesn't seem that
doesn't that seems much easier like
exactly you said that it was something
else that was written over
Trevor Morrissey says I discovered your
podcast some months back and have been
working my way through your entire
episode catalog which I've greatly
enjoyed after you start lamenting the
fact that you would no longer be able to
answer every question asked in the
monthly amas I was curious if you'd be
interested in a fun workaround of sorts
you could load all the unanswered
questions into a sports bracket and ping
the universe splitter and you spin up or
down to advance one of the questions in
each matchup until you're left with a
final question which you could answer we
could then claim tongue and Chico of
course that all questions will be
answered with a caveat that it might not
be in your branch of the wave function
I'm not trying to win the lottery or
anything so don't beat me up too much
just offering a lighthearted and
entertaining ways way to end each Ama
I completely agree that would be fun uh
it's also work for me I don't like work
or rather I have too much work doing
other things so what I'm gonna do since
you uh bring up the question if anyone
else wants to do this if anyone else
wants to go through the questions that I
don't answer put them in a bracket I
promise I will uh and then and then
sorry and then you also have to run the
random number generator which is easy to
find online a Quantum random number
generator let me know which question it
is next month I will answer it
schleier says so after your discussion
with Hugo Mercier do you think that
caliban my cat opens drawers for a
reason if it's too much to say that he
has a reason in his little cat brain
would you say that a reason exists
somewhere either in the universe as a
physical cause or maybe only once it is
inferred in the mind of a human Observer
yeah I think that Hugo's point is that
what we call reasons are in the minds of
human observers they're not out there in
the world and they're certainly not in
the minds of other animals so
I mean if that construal depends very
very much on exactly what you mean when
you say reason okay
and where the reason is located if I let
a ball roll down a hill is there a
reason why the ball rolls down the hill
well in some sense it's gravity and the
laws of physics and the shape of the
hill and things like that this is a
standard philosophical problem what
counts as the reason why or the cause or
whatever
um Hugo's point he's using the word
reason in the sense that it is something
given by a human being to help account
for or explain why they are doing
something so caliban loves opening
drawers he can't explain to you why he's
opening them so it is a very simple
answer to this question no caliban does
not open doors for a reason that doesn't
stop me from coming up with a reason why
caliban is opening the drawers just like
it doesn't stop me from coming up with
the reason why the ball is rolling down
a hill even though the ball doesn't have
a reason why it's just following the
laws of physics
William Benson asks a priority question
remember priority questions for those of
you who are new here every uh patreon
supporter gets a chance once in their
life to label an AMA question priority
and then I will do my best to answer it
even if I don't like it which I'm not
saying is true about your question
William so William's question is uh I am
57 and I've noticed over the past 10 or
15 years
10 I think I read that as 10 to the 15
but it's actually 10 to 15 very
different numerical range over the past
10 to 15 years a decline in my brain's
ability to store new short-term memories
new information comes into working
memory pushing out other details without
transferring those to short-term memory
I would like to become someone's
research subject in the hopes of
understanding and slowing down this
frustrating decline also if any new
therapies are out there I would love to
see if my condition can be reversed I'm
pretty sure I don't have dementia if you
or me how would you go about finding
researchers and studies that might be
interested in considering me as a
candidate to do research on perhaps
clinical researchers you've met have
told you some stories of how they have
found their human subjects or vice versa
so my apologies I know this is a
priority question but I have no idea how
to do this or at least whatever ID I
have it's certainly no better than yours
I would go to Google maybe go to gpt4 or
something like that in the modern era
and just ask you know how can I find
studies that are going on or something
like that I I have never
um I mean I do know people who are
clinical researchers or psychology
researchers or so forth they're
generally more academic psychologists
than medical doctors or medical
researchers so I don't really know
people who do researches on possible
therapies and therefore I've never
really talked to them about how they go
about finding subjects I think a lot of
them are at hospitals or at universities
and just ask students on campus if they
want to be in a study or something like
that but sometimes you see a call for
people to participate in studies I just
don't have any insight whatsoever on how
to go about finding it sorry about that
David witch w-i-c-h says what are your
opinions on the role of government in
areas of Science and Technology with
significant National Security interest
such as advanced machine learning
biotechnology cryptography and Quantum
Computing Etc in the last century we saw
examples an example of the government
putting significant resources toward the
advancement of nuclear technology for
the war effort should the government be
putting significant resources toward
advancing these emerging fields in the
public sector at National Labs and
institutes you know I think that's a
good question because the answer is a
very subtle one it's not there's no
simple answer to this one it depends on
many of the details for you know nuclear
technology for the war effort not only
did it have very obvious National
Security implications but it didn't have
very obvious commercial applications
right I mean maybe building a nuclear
power plant but that would be very
expensive not obvious that it's going to
make you a lot of money
so you needed the government to do it if
you wanted the research to be done at
all just like you do now with what we
call many fields of basic research or
fundamental research you know you're not
going to build ligo and detect
gravitational waves to make a lot of
money that's exactly the kind of
research that you need the government to
step in and do it but for something like
like you're mentioning machine learning
biotechnology cryptography Quantum
Computing these are all super duper
commercially exploitable okay if you can
do any one of these well you could in
principle make a lot of money so the
private sector has plenty of resources
and motivation to do well at it I think
that for various reasons you still want
some public funded research going on in
these things because you don't want all
the discoveries to be proprietary you
don't want all the important discoveries
in a field of science to be done by
private corporations that keep them for
themselves or patent them and don't let
anyone else use them therefore there's a
very good place for research done by
professors at universities being funded
by the government But It's Tricky I mean
right now we're in a situation where
with the AI Rush most of the
breakthroughs are being done by private
corporations why because they have the
money to spend on it hopeful to get more
money back in the future
there's plenty of people at universities
who are doing research on AI and some of
it is very important but they just don't
have quite the resources that you have
if you work for Google or Microsoft and
so forth and therefore their large
language models aren't quite as large
Etc uh you know nevertheless many
important breakthroughs biotechnology be
an obvious case example uh have been
done by people at universities or
National Labs or research institutes so
we have to keep that sector of our
research efforts thriving in my opinion
says my friends and I come to a
conclusion that your explanation of the
many worlds interpretation might be
incorrect as it contains the concepts of
measurement and forking to us this seems
like a remnant of the Copenhagen
interpretation the question is how does
the how the idea of measurement and
forking matches I never use forking by
the way branching is the word I use
probably you're thinking of
how does that match the simple picture
of the evolution of a Quantum system is
merely the rotation of a unit Vector in
Hilbert's space
well yeah I I mean I've said this I I
think that if you look carefully at
things that I've said you won't find
that much of a difference
um I've said many times that the ideas
of branching and so forth are useful to
human beings in exactly the same way
that ideas like entropy and temperature
are useful to human beings if you were a
classical statistical mechanic you would
believe that in principle laplace's
demon might know the position of
velocity of all the atoms in a gas but
you don't
and that matters that difference really
matters to you the best way of talking
about the gas is in terms of its
temperature and pressure and entropy and
so forth but not to laplace's demon
because all of those are approximate
coarse grained higher level emergent
ideas they help us with limited
knowledge and limited calculational
capacity to nevertheless say something
interesting but laplace's demon doesn't
need that opposite demon doesn't know
what a temperature is laplace's demon
knows what every single molecule in the
world is doing exactly the same way in
the ever interpretation of quantum
mechanics the fundamental description is
a wave function obeying the Schrodinger
equation that's it full stop period end
of story but that doesn't help we pour
limited cognitively bounded human beings
in coming to grips with what the world
actually looks like according to that
picture what the world looks like is we
put a spin through an experiment and we
see it either being spin up or spin down
and it's absolutely a crucial part of
the scientific Enterprise
matching your underlying theoretical
description to what you actually observe
and so for a human being trying to
understand how the world works it's not
sufficient to just say the there's a
wave function that obeys the Schrodinger
equation even if that's a true statement
you also want to explain why it looks
like wave functions collapse when you
measure them and the ever interpretation
has no problem doing that but that is a
absolutely important step in mapping
Everett onto reality
Eric stromquist says in earlier amas I
think you said that if a question isn't
answered it's fine to re-ask in another
AMA so I will give it a try that's
certainly True by the way you never know
what mood will strike me
just don't try to guilt me into asking a
question by asking it 20 times in a row
I find the research program you
described in something deeply hidden to
be very interesting the program that
tries to see if the metric structure of
space-time in gr can be emergent as a
consequence of entanglement
relationships encoded into the
hamiltonian in the energy basis that
would govern the evolution of the state
Vector of the universe in hilbert'space
the question is how is the program going
well you know to be honest it is going
but it's going slowly because I uh lost
all my graduate students not lost I
stopped taking new graduate students
when I knew I was leaving Caltech and
then I picked up and then I left and now
I have some books to write and I'm
slowly accumulating new graduate
students and postdocs Etc so it's been
rather slow going although there's still
a couple papers that are that are
percolating along behind the scenes
um and that's completely natural
honestly you know my way of thinking
about these things is by the way I'm not
the only person there's other people and
their research programs are going on uh
perfectly fine without my help but you
know this is a minority interest in the
larger picture of quantum gravity we
have a particular way of thinking about
things that I think is very promising
but in order to get other people
interested we're gonna have to do more
along the lines of getting good results
getting results to people that
constitute answers to people to
questions that people have had for a
long time and I think we can do that but
it takes time you know it's just it's
not something that goes on a
month-to-month time scale it's it's
slower than that even if it's going
forward
Nicholas sharovsky says sharovski yeah
as one of the consequences of the
replication crisis in Psychology open
science efforts have become an
increasingly aspect of important aspect
of the field in recent years in addition
to sharing data sets in cold and code
not talking very well today in addition
to sharing data sets in code
pre-registration is also part of this
effort to prevent bad research practices
P hacking file drawer problem Etc I
personally think that psychology has
benefited from this crisis and has
emerged stronger than ever what is your
take on open science how common are such
efforts in physics and where do you see
benefits and risks from more transparent
research
I think it's kind of heterogeneous
between Fields like different fields
address these questions very very
differently you know
as one example that I think would
qualify as a kind of open science you
have the preprint archive right
archive.org I remember when it started
and back in the 90s and it was started
by high energy physicists people doing
formal kind of stringy high energy
physics who were sharing preprints
anyway Paul Ginsburg and uh Joanne Cohn
and other people suggested uh that we uh
just do it on a computer we had a new
thing called the internet actually it
was first an email list even before it
was a web page and some people were
horrified when it became a web page like
I don't want to learn new technology
just to get my preprints but that is a
thing where you share all your research
results before they've been published
before they've been refereed and
anything anyone can comment and so forth
the whole world can see them for free
without subscribing to anything and so
forth
but there's different things that are
meant by open science so in mathematics
there have been some efforts where you
do literally do the research in an open
science kind of way so you pose a
question on a web page and then people
sort of Team collaborate online to try
to prove ethereum or something like that
that's very very rare in theoretical
physics and all the stuff about
registering so you say pre-registration
for those of you who don't know
is an attempt to address the question or
the issue that when you do an experiment
you might get a null result right you
might say well there's no effect I
didn't see any relationship between my
variables and traditionally it would be
difficult to get such a result published
in a psychology Journal right I didn't
see anything it's a hard case to make
and we have a set of numerical
quantitative
characterizations of when you have seen
something a level of statistical
significance that you're trying to reach
so basically just do a bunch of
experiments waiting to see something and
then when you see something you publish
it and when you don't you don't so the
problem with that is if you do enough
experiments you're bound to see
something just by random chance not
necessarily because there's actually
something going on so the idea of
pre-registration is some way that you
can say ahead of time I'm going to do
this experiment and therefore you if if
everyone does that and everyone says
with the results of their experiments
were they should go a lot further to
actually getting decent statistical
samples of when effects were real and
when they weren't uh something like that
isn't nearly as practical for physics
and theoretical physics you're not doing
an experiment you're not collecting data
okay in experimental physics it's very
often the case that either you're a
small lab doing something very very
specific but when you find it it it's
easy to tell people what it is and they
can replicate it right away or you're
doing big science at a giant particle
accelerator like the LHC and there's
only one eight Lac in the world it's
important to have two experiments at the
LHC Atlas and CMS so they can compare
each other's data when they found the
Higgs boson they both found it at the
same time that was a big step towards
making people believe they're on the
right track but you can't do 20
different things so I think that open
science is important and useful but the
ways in which it manifests itself are
going to be different for different
kinds of science I think that makes
perfect sense that's perfectly okay
Chris Gunter says if we discovered a
particle that violated the equivalence
principle I.E its inertial mass was not
the same as its gravitational Mass how
big of a disruption would that be to the
core Theory
consider a scalar factor between the two
zero gravitational mass or negative
gravitational Mass can a particle such
as this be modeled under GR
I think there's a couple things to say
about this question uh so for those of
you who know the equivalence principle
goes back to Galileo in some sense but
Einstein was the one who really put his
stamp on it the equivalence being
discussed is the equivalence between
gravitation and acceleration if you're
in a rocket ship with a very quiet
engine being accelerated at 1G you
wouldn't know the difference in that
between being on a room on the earth and
being in the 1G gravitational field that
we're in unlike being in an
electromagnetic field where you could
have charged particles that would move
differently everything behaves the same
under Gravity so it's a universal Force
that's the implication of the principle
of equivalence
but I think the right way of looking at
the principle of equivalence is as
inspiration it's not some deep
symmetry of physics or anything like
that it helped Einstein invent the idea
that space-time curvature is what gives
us gravity that's the the point of the
principle of equivalence but once you
have that idea you don't really need the
principle of equivalence anymore so one
implication one very weak version of the
principle of equivalent is that inertial
mass is equal to gravitational Mass so
again going back to Galileo and Newton
if you look at the equation of motion
Newton's Second Law f equals m a that is
the inertial mass it's saying that
there's some inertia in a body when you
put a force on it its acceleration
resists the object resists being
accelerated by an amount proportional to
its mass okay but then there's also the
gravitational Mass which is the amount
of gravitational force that a body
creates under Newton's theory of gravity
those happen to be equal Newton wondered
about this
um so the question is could you violate
that would it do by violence to general
relativity the answer is yes you can
easily violate it and no it does not do
that much violence because the principle
of equivalence is not some foundational
symmetry in fact we have theories that
do exactly that scalar tensor theories
such as the bronze Dickie theory in
those theories you have an extra scalar
field which is in some sense breaking
the relationship between the inertial
mass and gravitational Mass I say in
some sense because really the way to
talk about it is that those are acquaint
outdated Notions inertial mass and
gravitational mass at the end of the day
we have a theory defined by a lagrangian
that we vary to get equations of motion
that's what matters if you don't know
what any of those words mean I recommend
you read my book the biggest ideas in
the universe where I explain what some
of them are all about
Danny avidan says following my previous
questions a few months ago and some
conversations you had here since I was
wondering if you have a definition or a
notion of what constitutes a moral
subject that is where do we Mark the
line between things that we have a moral
responsibility for and things that we do
not or have less
I don't know that's a very good question
um I mean I have a I when I say I don't
know that's a little bit too clear but I
have a vague idea I do not have a
rigorous a very carefully delineated set
of criteria uh you know it's there's um
certainly part of it is just being
self-aware in some sense right
um but let me let me put a footnote here
there's there's a a an extension from
individuals to species or to categories
that we worry about but let me worry
about that in a second so it's as far as
individuals are concerned
um someone is self-aware Right conscious
able to respond to their environment
things like that but it's much more than
that I think that part of the linchpin
is something we talked about a little
bit with Janine Ismail back in the day
more recently with Adam bully and
Michael tomasello the ability of
imagination right to be a moral agent
you have to not only do certain things
but you have to be able to contemplate
different possible actions that you take
for many non-human animals they do
things right caliban opens his drawers
he likes doing that
um
not because he's sitting there thinking
well if I open the drawer then this
would happen and if I didn't then that
other thing would happen so I you know
imagine different hypothetical
counterfactual scenarios and decide
between them that kind of ability to
imagine the future and think about it I
think is an important part of being a
moral subject but like I said I don't
have a hard and fast uh set of
definitions there I think it's important
to do it I don't want to dismiss the the
question it's just not something I put a
lot of thought into
Johann luvgren says sometimes people
describe effective field Theory as a
framework for reductionism but sometimes
reductionism gets a bad rap EG
explanations of how water behaves
usually don't consider water water as
individual molecules what do you think
is there a difference between philosophy
of effective field theories and
reductionism
well this is a complicated batch of
questions hidden here so I'm not going
to go into great detail
um let me just say that I don't think
reductionism should get a bad rap
usually when you read
people who say bad things about
reductionism the things that they say
about reductionism are not really
recognizable to people who call
themselves reductionist uh reduction I
don't know any reductionist who says
that the best way to think about water
is as individual molecules in every
circumstance when you think about the
freezing point of water you're not
worried about the individual molecules
you're perfectly happy talking about the
higher level immersion properties of the
water a reductionist just wants to say
and there is a more comprehensive Theory
than thinking of water as a liquid solid
gas with certain points of phase
transitions there's a more comprehensive
theory that is just as accurate as that
theory but also valid in other regimes
like when you only have one or two water
molecules going around in the Notions of
freezing or boiling make no sense that
microscopic more comprehensive theory is
the reductionist one and they'd better
be compatible so any macroscopic
features that you have in water had
better be explicable in principle in
terms of the most comprehensive
description you have of water that's not
a
exhortation to action saying that you
should think about water that way under
all circumstances it's not even an
epistemological or methodological piece
of advice saying that it the most useful
effective helpful way of thinking about
it is in terms of water molecules of
course you think about things in the
language that is most appropriate to the
problem that you care about in the
moment so as far as effective field
theories go
um I'm not exactly sure what it means
when you say sometimes people describe
effective field Theory as a framework
for reductionism I mean effective field
theory is a framework for those of you
who don't know the idea of effective
field Theory which I'll be talking about
a lot in book two of the biggest ideas
in the universe
um is that you can develop a theory of
the low energy parts of your Quantum
field Theory what we call the infrared
long wavelength low energy parts of your
Quantum field Theory without knowing all
the details of the ultraviolet high
energy parts so you don't need to know
quantum gravity to do the standard model
of particle physics you don't need to
know the standard model particle physics
to do chemistry you don't need to know
chemistry to do biology Etc so I think
that understanding how effective field
theories work might help you be a
reductionist but I don't know if it's I
don't know what it means to say that
it's a framework for reductionism sorry
about that
you usually by the way usually you know
for these kinds of questions sometimes
people say I've always found it helpful
to actually find someone saying that
because it's too easy to paraphrase or
oversimplify when you say sometimes
people say things like this like find a
person who says it and then we can talk
about that
Caitlyn says like Keith who asked a
question the March AMA I've recently
been reading about statistical physics
techniques in Neuroscience in general
I've noticed that mathematical biology
is pretty dominated by current and
former physicists how important is it to
learn like the physics of physics before
studying the physics of Neuroscience or
the physics of democracy
well I think it's helpful for two
reasons one is that you don't know ahead
of time which parts of physics are going
to be useful in the study of something
else whether it's Neuroscience or the
atmosphere or democracy or whatever so
just studying physics for its own sake I
think is uh helpful because you might
realize that oh this thing you didn't
think was very useful suddenly has an
application that is kind of interesting
and important but the other thing is you
know to be again a little bit
reductionist about it as we were being
in the last question
physics comes closer to being that
comprehensive underlying microscopic
description of the world than any other
science does so you can certainly study
Neuroscience or democracy knowing
nothing about physics at all that's fine
they are independent autonomous
subject matters that you might be
interested in but they had better be
compatible with the underlying
principles of physics usually they are
and it's just automatic you don't have
to check it but it's another way of
thinking about what is going on here
so the reason why you might want to
study the physics of physics first
rather than studying neuroscience and
then the physics of Neuroscience Etc
is because there's an arrow that points
in a certain direction okay there is a
physics of Neuroscience there's not that
much Neuroscience of physics
Neuroscience doesn't help you understand
the standard model standard model
doesn't help you understand Neuroscience
either but the ideas or laws of physics
the the ways that you think about
Physics help you understand Neuroscience
in a way that the ways you think about
Neuroscience aren't as useful in
understanding physics so I don't think
it's quite a symmetric relationship
between the different subject matters
David milock says is it possible is the
possibility of machine Consciousness not
any particular machine but in general
something that is for you subject to a
Credence if so what evidence could lead
you to updating your credence
it depends what you mean by Machine
Consciousness I think that the the issue
here is not so much that there's a 75
chance that machines will someday be
conscious as it is that we don't know
what it means to say some days machines
will be conscious my suspicion is that I
guess we never said this explicitly but
maybe it's been implicit in various
episodes there's more than one aspect to
Consciousness just like when we talk to
Stuart Bartlett about the meaning of
life and he said look there's lots of
different things that go on in a living
being and they could be independent from
each other I think there's a lot of
different things going on in conscious
creatures and some of them might appear
in machines before others so I you know
we need to do more than let let's put it
this way and this is often a way that I
think about philosophy problems I think
you get yourself into a philosophical
conundrum by taking a concept that has
been very useful to you and just
insisting that it's there and it's just
that we don't know what the death
definition of it is and then trying to
figure out what the right definition of
it is like Consciousness maybe the
question isn't what's the right
definition of Consciousness maybe the
there's a question that is much more
operational and down to earth what are
the different aspects we have in mind
when we talk about Consciousness for
non-machine things and then we can think
about the likelihood of them appearing
in machines but my Credence is very high
that essentially anything that can be
done by a human being could in principle
be done by machines so I don't think
that there's any barrier in principle to
that I have no strong credences for when
different things are going to happen
that's a prediction that I would not be
very good at making
hugin says what do you think is the best
explanation for the Higgs getting its
mass
I'm going to be disappointing answer
here but it'll be an Illuminating answer
there's no such thing as the explanation
for why the Higgs gets its mass I know
why you think there might be because in
talking about the Higgs we very often
talk about the masses of other particles
like the W boson or the electron or
whatever and say the Higgs helps explain
why these particles get their Mass and
then you might be led to ask well what
explains why the Higgs gets its mass
which is you know 125 GED or whatever it
is because there's a question that is
that is implicit in the original one to
the extent that you say do I need an
explanation for why particles have mass
or can they just have it
and the thing is that if you just have a
Quantum field theory of ordinary Fields
you don't work too hard you don't impose
certain symmetries etc etc particles can
just have mass like Paul Dirac didn't
need to work hard to explain the mass of
the electron in the Dirac equation he
just put it in that's all it is the
reason why we have to work so hard in
the standard model of particle physics
to get particles mass is because there
are symmetries that naively prohibit
particles from getting masses particles
like the electron like the Gage bosons
the w and z bosons Etc and nevertheless
they seem to have it so this was a late
appearing problem it was only in the 50s
and 60s once we started understanding
Mill symmetries and parity violation and
things like that that we realized it was
hard to both have these kinds of fields
in our theories and have these
symmetries be respected or violated as
the case may be so and then Stephen
Weinberg figured out that the Higgs
could help explain how to reconcile
those two things the idea that these
particles needed to have mass and they
need to have these symmetries so
typically if you don't have these
symmetries protecting your particles
from getting a mass you don't need a
Higgs or anything else particles can
just have mass and when it comes to the
Higgs boson itself there is no symmetry
that makes the Higgs boson not have a
mass it can just have whatever Mass it
wants in fact the problem is the
opposite it can literally have whatever
Mass it what it wants and therefore by
the philosophy of effective field theory
that we were just talking about there
are ultraviolet effects that contribute
to the mass of the Higgs boson and you
would expect if you didn't work very
hard that the Higgs boson should have a
very very large mass much larger than
the mass it actually has that's
basically the hierarchy problem of
particle physics why is the master Higgs
so low compared to what its natural
expectation is so that's the problem why
is the Hig have why is the Higgs have so
little Mass not where does it get this
Mass from at all
Jesse rimler says in the April AMA who
identified yourself as a pro-housing
yimby yes in my backyard as opposed to
an anti-housing NIMBY not in my backyard
a critique of the Envy movement is it is
ultimately it is ultimately a gift to
large developers deregulation allows
them to build luxury housing for large
profits yimbe's claimed this increased
supply of any kind will bring prices
down but this some says trickle-down
economics all over again an alternate
path would be to advocate for regulated
affordable public housing to address the
immediate concerns of homelessness and
low-income housing scarcity what do you
think of these arguments
I certainly don't think that those are
our arguments not to be aimby I mean
yimbi's just say build a lot of Housing
and some of it will be luxury housing
for large profits some of it won't be
just make it easier to build housing
even low income non-luxury housing can
still be profitable for Builders I think
a lot of people who are against letting
developers build apartment buildings at
all just don't like the idea that anyone
should be making money off of this and I
do not have that moral objection I'm
fine with people making money the more
Supply you have of housing the lower the
cost is going to be as a general rule I
don't care who makes the money you can
always tax the rich I mean very much in
favor of taxing the rich and spreading
the wealth from doing that but not
letting housing be built is not the way
to do that by all means also build
regulated affordable public housing do
that too but guess what we don't have
enough regulated affordable public
housing right now and if you stop people
from building new apartments you're just
making the problems worse
Philip Stickney says thinking about
moral luck would you change aspects of
our justice system when it comes to
something like reckless driving versus
reckless driving and hitting someone
supposing the two situations are
identical barring one resulting and
hitting someone
you know I thought about this I want to
say I thought about a lot but that's an
exaggeration I thought about a little
bit the idea of moral luck is that we
tend to
uh either punish or reward people on the
basis of things that happen
and you might think that's a sensible
thing to do but there's an alternative
that says well shouldn't we publish
reward people on the basis of what could
have happened given what they were doing
right is there really a principle
justification for giving people
different punishments if they drive
drunk if they do or do not hit someone I
mean what they did was driving drunk
that was the problematic thing if they
hit someone that's too bad but arguably
the punishment should be just as severe
if they don't
um and I do think that they're I get the
force of this argument I feel it it does
seem sensible to me I think that there
are practical problems I mean the the I
should reveal hidden behind the scenes
here there's always a poker analogy
going on in my mind
um poker players will make fun of or
criticize other players for being too
results oriented
you might think that in certain aspects
of human endeavor being results oriented
is good right but in poker that means
you're paying too much attention to how
you did at the end of the day when the
cards are revealed and not enough
attention to how you are playing you
should be process oriented because you
will always get unlucky sometimes and
get lucky other times but you can't
control that you can control what you do
so a poker player would very much
appreciate this argument about moral
luck but I think in the real world
there's a practical problem it's just
hard to know that someone was doing a
behavior that had a certain probability
of leading to a bad outcome or something
like that I think that in some Ideal
World where we were laplace's demon and
we knew even better than LaPlace demon
we knew all the counter factual worlds
where we could say well in this number
of possible Worlds the fraction of them
in which something bad happened because
of your behavior was the following right
um if we could do that
then we could probably punish people or
reward them on the basis of what they
were doing rather than what the outcomes
were in the real world that just seems
to really open things up for abuse in
all sorts of terrible ways because we're
not very good at knowing exactly
um what the probabilities are of bad
outcomes I think that it is defensible
to say that our punishments should be
higher than maybe they are for things
that that reasonable people would agree
had a large chance of leading to
something bad you know the NBA playoffs
are going on and um
I'm rooting for the 76ers of course
their coaches Doc Rivers there have been
recent
controversies over players getting
ejected or suspended for different
actions on the court and uh you know one
of the things is you know Doc Rivers was
saying
he was overall in favor of not
suspending or ejecting people too
quickly because what tends to happen in
the real world is that there is a
provocation some one player does
something to provoke the other and then
there's a retaliation and the referees
see the retaliation and punish you they
don't see the provocation and so they
that person doesn't get punished and so
there's an imbalance there how to deal
with that so there's questions here of
practical reason the real world we don't
know everything we have to be humble in
our ability to figure things out and to
predict the future that those
considerations have to go in to these
questions
Pete Faulkner says having just finished
reading Jim peoples's book cosmology
century and listening to your responses
at the start of last month's AMA has got
me thinking about how science moves
forward it's certainly nothing like the
a therefore B hence C timeline that many
assume given the way advances tend to be
popularly reported peoples makes clear
the many dead ends and wrong turns taken
over the years in the development of the
Modern Standard cosmology as well as the
breakthroughs that were not seen as such
at the time do you have thoughts about
ideas or papers that you are aware of
which may fall into either of these two
categories dead ends or unappreciated
breakthroughs
well my only thought is the following
that people should be a little bit more
forgiving of dead ends and unappreciated
breakthroughs it's easy very easy and if
you know anything about the history of
science to come up with examples of both
you know when I was in graduate school
and we were thinking about large-scale
structure in the universe there was it
was well known that inflationary
cosmology was a candidate for
um generating the tiny density
perturbations that would grow into
galaxies and structure today but there
was another candidate cosmic strings
cosmic strings could easily be formed in
the early universe and they could
generate the perturbations that give
rise to galaxies and structures and
honestly up until the moment when we
started seeing the temperature and
isotropies in the cosmic microwave
background both of these were very
viable and I'll even be more honest the
cosmic string scenario in many ways was
more robust than the inflationary
scenario you need to do less fiddling
and complexifying and fine-tuning to get
the right kinds of cosmic strings than
you do to get the right inflationary
perturbations but
he then saw the microwave background and
both theories made predictions in the
cosmic string predictions were wildly
ruled out they were not compatible with
what we saw the basic problem was that
the inflationary predictions are all
made very early and they sort of evolve
in lockstep ever since then whereas the
cosmic string predictions Cosmic string
perturbations are constantly being
generated all the time so they're
qualitatively very different in what you
predict for the CMB and the inflationary
the primordial perturbations as we call
them one out but I don't think it was a
dead end how did you know how would have
you have known right it was a perfectly
reasonable Theory they're also
unappreciated breakthroughs we already
mentioned Stephen Weinberg in 1967
showing that you could explain the mass
of the of the particles in the standard
model what we now call the standard
model with the Higgs boson he wrote that
paper in 1967 and nobody noticed nobody
cared even Weinberg himself didn't cite
his own paper for the next five years
until it was a tuft enveltman who showed
that the theory was renormalizable and
then suddenly now it's the most cited
paper in the history of theoretical
physics or something like that so those
things can happen all the time so my
only Grand statement about those things
is that
live with it
in fact expect it anticipated you can't
say well this Theory didn't work
therefore we shouldn't have thought
about it at the time unless you can give
a principled reason that would have been
available to the people at the time then
they weren't doing anything wrong and
you know even that is hard because it's
too easy to wait until we know the
answer and then go oh yes I know that
should have been the answer all along I
can give you the following reasons why
blah blah blah it's hard that's why you
have to treat science as an ongoing
messy back and forth between different
people with different ideas different
styles different predilections Etc and
see what comes out what's important is
that you let different ideas go forward
you don't decide too early that only one
way of doing things is the right way and
that you are open to listening to people
pursuing different ideas giving their
sales pitches for their favorite ideas
and seeing what comes out at the end
Jason ricciardi says one of the most
impactful positives and negatives of the
future of Life institute's call on all
AI labs to immediately pause for at
least six months the training of AI
systems more powerful than gpt4 and what
would an idealize real world roll out
look like across the globe so I think I
already answered this early by accident
I probably had vaguely remembered that
Jason had asked this question
um I don't think it's a good idea like
it's a practical matter okay like I'm
very much sympathetic with the idea that
we should be cautious that we should be
careful that we should really think
about what we're doing here we're
unleashing something what is it how we
gonna put it to where we absolutely have
to do that as a practical down-to-earth
person the idea that we sort of politely
ask different Labs that are competing
for money and first mover advantages to
just stop for six months that just
sounds hopeless to me so I don't think
that's the right way to go I have no
idea what the right way actually is
Alexandra Marcotte says taking into
account the fact that it requires
millions of years to complete a full
rotation how do we evaluate the impact
of Dark Matter on the rotational
velocity of galaxies well you have
already answered your question it's the
rotational velocity that matters not the
time it takes to go around the whole
thing it's true that it takes a long
time for stars to complete a full orbit
around the outside of a galaxy but you
don't need to follow them for a full
orbit you just need to know what their
average velocities are right now or not
just stars but gas and dust and things
like that and that we can get from the
Doppler effect this is what uh Vera
Rubin and Company did back in the 70s
they looked at the Doppler shifted
radiation from things at the outskirts
of galaxies to measure their velocities
and then on average those velocities are
going to be the rotational velocity of
that you need to stay in orbit there's
some assumptions there right that it's
more or less equilibrated and so forth
but you know nowadays we have better
evidence for Dark Matter than that that
and we find out those assumptions were
more or less on the right track
Daniel Donaldson says with all the
discussion around marvels of chat GPT
and other AI do you think that if they
decide to answer all questions quote
until you fix the climate issues Nothing
Else Matters climate change deniers will
finally accept the truth my guess is no
however as a bonus if you answer this
question your YouTube will go through
the roof so I think that both know they
will not do that uh and climate change
deniers will finally not accept the
truth and it will not cause my YouTube
numbers to go through the roof none of
those things are true but also the
reason why I'm answering this question
is it's not true that until you fix the
climate issues nothing else matters even
if you think which is at least a
respectable position to have that fixing
climate change is the single most
important thing we can multitask we
human beings we have the ability to do
more than one thing at a time I'm not on
the side of people who believe that you
shouldn't do other good things just
because this good thing still needs to
be done we should do all the good thing
things I think we have the capacity to
do at least many good things all at the
same time
Dave grundengeiger says Layman physics
Enthusiast here with the year of General
Physics in college and a lifetime of
Pops eye reading my question is since
gravity warps space-time what does it
mean when we talk about fractions of a
second after the big bang how can we
talk meaningfully about a second in that
extremely warped space-time how does it
relate to us here and now how should we
think about it well the different ways
to answer this question the most basic
one of which is to say that there are
different ways in which space-time can
be warped in particular if you look at
the space time of an expanding Universe
in general relativity the kind of space
time the so-called Robertson Walker
metric that we use to describe the
universe to a good approximation and
general relativity
space can be warped but time is not time
is just time
one way of thinking about how this could
be true if there's so much matter and
energy near the Big Bang is if you say
the time is Warped you have to say
compared to what right when you're
talking about time as a dimension and
measuring distances in that Dimension
you're talking about what clocks read
and so what do clocks read compared to
what there is something called a second
and if you have a clock whether it's
from some atomic clock from some Atomic
transitions or a mechanical clock and it
ticks off a second
even if that clock is near the big bang
and therefore surrounded by other matter
and energy all the other matter and
energy is also surrounded by modern
energy and it's all in the same
situation
so everything that feels the passage of
one second is going to feel the passage
of one second and measure it to be one
second so there's no difference between
clocks doing one thing and clock's doing
another thing that's in contrast to a
black hole or even the gravitational
field of the Earth where you do have a
difference if there's a clock that is
hanging out near the Event Horizon of a
black hole that's different than a clock
that is over here so you can have
different amounts of time elapsing on
those two clocks if you were to compare
them nearby
this is just another way of saying that
even though the universe is rapidly
expanding near the Big Bang it's
homogeneous and isotropic so it's the
same throughout space so there's no
difference in how time is passing from
place to place
qubit says why is it that even though
we've understood the process of
decoherence in particular within the
framework of quantum Darwinism
scientists still talk about the
measurement problem is completely
unsolved why isn't that explanation
sufficient and what is still missing in
order to settle the debate
so what's missing in order to settle the
debate about the measurement problem is
you still need to talk about the
foundations of quantum mechanics you
need to have an ontology
and people don't agree on what the
ontology is so to go back a little bit
for those who are not experts by D
coherence what we mean is that if you
have a if you try like shorting or tried
with the Schrodinger cat experiment to
set up a situation where you put a not
just a microscopic thing like an
electron or an atom into a Quantum
superposition but to try to put a
macroscopic thing into a Quantum
superposition like an awake cat or in a
sleep cat
decoherence is the fact that macroscopic
things or even sometimes microscopic
things but certainly macroscopic things
are constantly interacting with their
environment with the air in the room the
photons in the room and so forth the
infrared light given off by warm objects
all around you this is all stuff that is
interacting with you and if you're a
macroscopic object
that stuff interacts with you
differently depending on which part of
the superposition that you're in if
you're in a wake cat or in a sleep cat
different photons will hit you and be
absorbed so you become entangled with
the environment very very quickly and
that's decoherence
it's a well-known fact that if you let
decoherence happen and then you look
just at the quantum state of the system
so you forget the environment okay you
ignore it that's creating the
constructing the density Matrix that we
talked about earlier construct the
density Matrix for the system tracing
out as we say the environment ignoring
the environment
then because of decoherence it's well
known that the elements of the density
Matrix take the form of a probability
distribution
they are numbers between 0 and 1 and
they add up to one
and they act for all the world like a
probability and in fact in the case
where you were just going to be a
Copenhagen person and say the
probability is the wave function squared
the probability of collapse onto
something that is the number that you
get in the density Matrix that wave
function squared so what you have after
d coherence described by the density
Matrix of the object is an ensemble of
different states weighted by their born
rule probabilities okay so therefore it
is for all intents and purposes as if
there's a probability distribution over
these measurement outcomes but that
doesn't mean that it is a probability
distribution over these measurement
outcomes you need an extra sentence or
two or three so one extra sentence might
be that that whole Quantum State whether
it's the pure State before or the
density Matrix after
represents real parts of reality okay
that the different parts of the density
Matrix are all simultaneously real
that's what you would say if you
believed in many worlds if you thought
many worlds was the best theory they're
all different branches of the wave
function weighted differently in the
density Matrix but you could also say
that some magical thing happens
and there is only one element of the
density Matrix that truly represents
reality and what those elements of the
density Matrix are telling you is just
the probability of being in one or the
other that would be a different physics
that would be different laws of nature
okay to erase the other terms in the
density Matrix and to point your finger
at one of them and say this one is the
real world in which we live fine you
have done something you've made a new
Theory of physics but tell me exactly
when that Erasure happened that Erasure
is just the collapse of the wave
function so everyone agrees that t
coherence gives you a probability
distribution but what they don't agree
on is the physics underlying what is
going on and the physics still matters
okay I'm going to group together two
questions one is from Emmett Francis who
says do you have a typical response to
the claim often made by Christian
apologists that materialism physicalism
is self-defeating for context the basic
idea is summarized into C.S Lewis quote
as if naturalism were true then all
thoughts whatever would be wholly the
result of irrational causes it cuts its
own throat
and Brendan says how do you respond to
people who say the laws of nature you
know the forces of gravity
electromagnetism Etc are so persistent
and consistent that it must have had a
Creator to me this sounds like a similar
argument of why there's something rather
than nothing curious to hear your
thoughts on it so both of these I don't
know why you know this happens sometimes
in the amas where we get similar
questions just out of the blue from
different people even though I didn't
talk about these things recently but
that's fine
um
they both are different aspects of what
I think is a pretty common
impulse or intuition I'm not quite sure
what to call it feeling among people who
are not physicalists materialists
whether they're religious or something
else they they want there to be a
certain kind of explanation or even I
would go so far as to say a certain kind
of governance in how nature Works they
don't want to think that it is possible
for nature to just be
and they they get this impression uh by
dealing with little subsets of nature
that we deal with in our everyday lives
right uh you know you know that if you
have some machine like your car or
whatever and you don't constantly
maintain it it's gonna break down and
you also know that that car didn't just
pop out of existence randomly so in the
real world in our everyday lives when we
see structures that are organized and
working towards some purpose and so
forth they're always maintained for some
reason by some intelligent agent or and
so forth so the mistake that these
people are making is saying therefore I
expect the universe and all of reality
to follow that same Paradigm so in the
C.S Lewis quote he says if naturalism
were true then all thoughts whatever
would be wholly the result of irrational
causes so how do we interpret what he's
what he's saying there is not the
clearest statement ever made but you
know the thoughts are going on in your
brain and he's saying look if you're
just natural if you're just physical
like the physicalist would have you
believe then that's just you know things
bumping into each other there's no
guidance there there's no uh reason why
the particular things should be bumping
around in your brain in the particular
way that they are and the reason why I
say that the sentence is not clear is
because it's not quite clear what the
objection is maybe he said it elsewhere
it's a tiny quote you know I'm not I'm
trying to be fair to Lewis but I can
imagine two different true objections to
this one is
the sort of initial conditions question
that the particular neurons firing and
so forth that are going on in your brain
don't have any reason to represent or
reflect reality right I mean they're
just bumping around in your brain but I
think we know the answer to that I mean
through various things with evolutionary
biology and the laws of physics and so
forth they're perfectly good reasons why
the actual thoughts we have in our
brains as uh coming out of the physical
processes in our brains should correctly
reflect the outside world we talked a
little bit with Andy Clark about this
just last week
um
you know people try to make arguments
well you know if uh
uh Evolution were true then our brains
and our bodies would just be maximized
for survival not maximized for truth
well yeah but truth is really helpful to
survival correctly understanding how the
world works and what's going to happen
is actually really helpful if you want
to make it from day to day so in that
sense I don't think it's any argument as
to why uh the things that are going on
in your brains should reflect correctly
the outside world
the other possible construal of the
sentence that I could imagine is the
very action of the neurons in your brain
or the atoms in your brain that allows
them to reflect the outside world relies
on the laws of physics being obeyed
right in other words the things that
happen in your brain aren't truly random
from moment to moment they follow the
patterns that we call the laws of
physics
um why do they do that why is there any
regularity to the world at all and you
know there's a it's a reasonable
question to ask but the unreasonable
thing would be to have a presumption
that you need something to hold it
together
need something to enforce the laws of
nature right the the word law makes you
think of the analogy with actual laws
passed by governments and so forth and
laws need an enforcer right they need a
legislature and they need enforcement
mechanisms but that's just a bad analogy
I mean that's not a really rigorous
argument it's it is a true fact about
nature that it has patterns in it that
obeys laws I have no way of judging
whether that should be surprising or
whether that should be the most natural
thing in the world but it is what it is
in the world and to say and it's because
God Did It In My Mind adds nothing to
our understanding of it so same thing is
true for um I mean that's basically
exactly what Brendan was getting at the
idea that the fact that the laws are so
consistent and persistent there must be
a Creator why
did that why did you ever get that that
idea I can imagine that you're just
incorrectly porting over intuition you
get from dealing with cars and so forth
in your everyday life but the universe
isn't like that I had no reason to think
that it being lawlike is any weirder or
more surprising than it would be if it
were not law like maybe someday we will
know but now we certainly don't
Paul Hess says in the April AMA you
talked about whether the concept of
emergence can be used with respect to
human societies this may be curious to
hear your thoughts about an adjacent
topic do you subscribe to the great man
or great person theory of History where
individual leaders Drive the course of
human history or do you subscribe to
something more like historical
materialism where the bulk forces like
economics technology and culture Drive
the evolution of human history
well I think if you go back way back
into the archives of the podcast you'll
find a conversation with Ed Watts who is
a historian of the Roman Empire
and that conversation was I guess I
should include that more some sometimes
people ask like what was the podcast
episode that changed your mind the most
or gave you the most ideas that that
should absolutely be one of them because
if you go back to the decline of the
Roman I might have said Empire what I
meant was the decline in their own
Republic the
um turning of the Roman Republic into
the Roman Empire why did that happen and
Ed Watts tells a story you know it's a
version of a story that plenty of other
people have told about the grocky
brothers and them assembling mobs to
intimidate the Senate and things like
that and I asked you know isn't that too
much
credit or blame whichever you want being
given to just a small number of people
and isn't that uh too much like the
individual great person theory of
history and I thought we moved past that
and his answer was well most of the time
you can imagine that any one person is
not going to be able to affect the
large-scale sweep of history that much
but there are crucial moments when
things could go one way or the other and
the traditional deterministic historical
materialism kind of
um considerations are not going to tell
you what happens and an individual can
have a huge impact and as a physicist
someone who knows about phase
Transitions and Chaos Theory and things
like that this makes a hundred percent
perfect sense the thing about history
you think about human beings and this is
relevant to the physics of democracy
also is that on the one hand there are a
lot of people so there's some collective
behavior when we think about history or
Society or democracy on the other hand
people are individually complex and hard
to predict and they interact with each
other in very strong and unpredictable
ways so even though there are a lot of
people it's not like a box of gas where
the individual particles in the gas are
very simple-minded and linear in their
responses so I think that it depends is
the answer there are absolutely r
bulk forces like economics technology
and culture that drive the evolution of
human history to a large extent but I
think that if you sat down we're nowhere
near being able to do this but if you
sat down with those forces and tried to
make predictions you wouldn't end up
predicting specific detailed historical
events you would predict Trends and
probabilities and the different
probabilities might describe very
different trajectories a tiny push right
at the right moment can put Society on a
very different path so I think it's both
I think there's a lot of deterministic
historial historical materialism and
there's a place for individuals to have
outsize influences at particular moments
Brad malt says do you think we'll ever
be able to detect the cosmic neutrino
background and what might we learn if we
could so the short answer is I'm not the
person to ask about whether we should do
this or not I'm not a neutrino
experimentalist I don't even know I've
heard people talk about uh detecting the
neutrino background for those of you who
are not up on it just like the big bang
created a whole bunch of photons that we
can now observe as the cosmic microwave
background it also created a whole bunch
of neutrinos if you might if you might
want to know why those two why photons
and neutrinos they are the massless or
nearly massless very low mass particles
that were in thermal equilibrium at
Early times and just stuck around as the
universe expanded and cooled there could
be other low mass particles like axions
but they were never in thermal
equilibrium there are other particles
like electrons that were in thermal
equilibrium but they mostly just
annihilate away so neutrinos and photons
are most of the Relic particles so there
is a neutrino background as well as a
photo ton background
I hope we can detect it but that there's
a technology question there right I
don't know what the sensitivity of the
detectors is I will say
we have very very strong evidence for
the existence of the neutrino background
indirectly through cosmology through
observations of the cosmic microwave
background and large-scale structure in
the early Universe when it was radiation
dominated there's a certain period where
the photons and the neutrinos where most
of the energy in the universe and
there's a certain period later where
it's matter dominated in dark matter and
ordinary matter are dominating but at
that moment when it was radiation
dominated and that includes the
neutrinos as well as honest goodness
photons the number of photons the
density of the cosmic neutrino
background affected the evolution of
large-scale structure so not only can
you absolutely see that there had to be
neutrinos you can put limits on their
masses if they were too heavy then there
wouldn't be enough of them to have the
effects that they actually have so you
can put an upper limit on the mass of
neutrinos that way if you could detect
it it depends on the details of how you
detected what we would learn otherwise I
don't have any great predictions about
that
Vicki Ramsey says I've heard you speak
and write upon the subject of time
dilation with regards to General and
special relativity as in what is the
correct way to think about the
predictions of time dilation from a
theoretical point of view but I would
love to hear your thoughts on actual
time dilation experiments such as the
nist 2010 and the more recent 2022 Jilla
experiments my question is is there
anything about these experiments that
causes you to update your priors
short answer no
um I didn't expect that there would be
because these experiments are exactly
what you would predict the experimental
results that we actually obtained are
exactly what you would predict from
general relativity and special
relativity and those are already very
much baked in to what my priors are the
experiments are still worth doing though
for two reasons one is they can lead to
technological advances that could be
very important for various things and
even better for someone like me maybe
they wouldn't have agreed with the
predictions and if that had happened
that would very much cause me to update
my priors but it didn't so far all the
experiments that have been done on time
dilation Etc have been very compatible
with the predictions of general
relativity
Sean virtue says am I correct in
thinking that the number of dimensions
in Hilbert space the number of degrees
of freedom in the universe the number of
possible variations of the wave function
of the universe and the number of
possible Arrangements of all particles
in the universe are all the same number
you are on the right track but not
exactly correct
um for one thing let's just eliminate
that last bit the number of possible
Arrangements of all particles in the
universe the universe is not made of
particles if you if you want to ask
questions about the fundamental nature
of the universe at this level of
specificity you have to take into
account though it's a Quantum field
Theory Universe we're talking about not
a particle universe so in some sense
there's something like this but you have
to talk about the number of possible
Arrangements of all the quantum Fields
And even there it's not very accurate
because probably field Theory doesn't
work all the way down to situations
where quantum gravity and the Planck
scale is important things like that so
let's let's eliminate that Clause from
the statement what you're basically
getting at is is there a relationship
between the dimensionality of Hilbert's
face and the number of degrees of
freedom or variations of stuff in the
universe and the answer there is
basically yes there's one very very tiny
footnote will put there
if you have let's say two-dimensional
Hilbert space okay so a single qubit
how many degrees of freedom do you have
so you have a single qubit that can
either be spin up or spin down so it's a
little Vector that's pointing toward the
spin up part of Direction in hilber
space for the spin down Direction in
Hilbert's space you might say well I
have two degrees of freedom but of
course you don't you have a single qubit
right if I tell you the amplitude the
size of the amplitude the modulus that
is I have the amplitude of the spin up
part
that I know instantly the size of the
amplitude for the spin down part so
there's only one degree of Freedom there
even though it's two-dimensional Hilbert
space that's nitpicking I'm not going to
make a big deal out of it but I take it
from this question that nitpicking is
encouraged so that's what I'm giving you
Antoine Chapin says you said you were
busy book writing could you share with
us what this process looks like for you
since idea Inception I guess from oh
since in the sense of
ever since idea Inception to publishing
what are the main steps to write a book
and which ones do you find most least
enjoying along the way
well you're in luck a couple of years
ago I did a holiday message on exactly
this so you'd have to look it up but at
the end of 2020
one maybe
um maybe 2020 I forget but I did a
little uh solo
podcast episode talking about exactly
this so you can get much more details
there
um the whole process is it takes a very
long time you have to invent the idea of
the book and do a little research you
have to think about whether or not it's
a good idea I mean the number of ideas I
have for books is way larger than the
number of books I will ever write
um you have to get a contract with a
publisher the whole bit get an outline
do research write the book and then you
give the book to both your editor at the
publishing house and your friends to
read and then you get comments and you
revise you get figures made that might
be the least enjoyable part getting the
figures made uh Jason torchinski who is
a former mindscape guest is my favorite
illustrator and he is great if you ever
see any non-stick figure illustrations
in my books they've been done by Jason
you know the picture of Maxwell's demon
uh and so forth from in from eternity to
here one of my favorite images that he
ever made but there's there's many in
the different books
um but you have to get them done and you
know who has time for that I'll tell you
that the biggest ideas in the universe
is a special challenge because I know
something could be groaning and some of
you will think this is perfectly obvious
but
publishing houses
trade publishing houses like my
publisher Dutton that is part of penguin
will only take manuscript submissions in
Microsoft Word
that's it so if you're used to being a
scientist and typing a text with lots of
equations of course you're going to use
law Tech or some flavor thereof and
you're used to doing that and it makes
perfect sense and it's meant for that
and it's easy and it's almost as easy as
just writing text
putting equation into Microsoft Words is
terrible it's just it doesn't work all
the time and it's fussy and whatever and
it greatly slows me down and and causes
also I'm trying to like be on a roll and
get text written right so that's that's
annoying but you know I get it usually I
won't even use Microsoft Word to write a
book I'll use scrivener scrivener is a
wonderful program that lets you keep the
whole project in sort of separate
sub-files you have one big document that
is your whole book but you can have
separate sub-files for different
chapters and for uh you know PDF files
and figures and resources and then
scrivener is very very helpful for
organizing that and then
you can output the parts of it that you
want to Output as a Microsoft Word
document but that only works if it's all
text once you get to equations scrivener
is not up to the task so yeah this one
is is more painful than the average and
then of course there's copy editing and
you have to record the audio book and
then you have to like give some talks
when it comes out look I like the whole
thing I love writing books I mean the
thing uh that I'm really feeling right
now and I'm in the finishing stages of
writing book two of the biggest ideas
which is quanta in fields where I do I
actually do not that much quantum
mechanics well it's all quantum
mechanics but quantum mechanics as
quantum mechanics is just going to be a
quick three chapters at the beginning
and then Quantum field Theory and
particle physics and Feynman diagrams
are most of the book as they were for
the videos and I really love explaining
it getting it right thinking about it
it's work because you know like you want
to say this is that the best way of
doing it that's the way that all the
physicists do it but is it the best way
to be understandable to people who are
not physicists it's a fun kind of
Challenge and puzzle and you know I
succeed halfway maybe I don't succeed
all the way but I'm trying and I'm
learning things myself along the way
Andrew Goldstein says or Goldstein sorry
David walpert recently wrote an essay on
how to study Concepts Beyond imagination
a plane of knowledge beyond the grasp of
human Minds I was intrigued by the
notion that advances in artificial
intelligence might reveal fewer
cognitive limits than human thoughts and
perceptions do you have any thoughts on
Wilbert's suggestion
well I haven't I know David very well I
think he's a brilliant guy but I haven't
read that essay that you're pointing to
I will say two things I think there's a
there's not having read the essay so not
knowing what David is talking about
there's two different questions one is
are there statements that would qualify
as knowledge right true statements about
math or physics or whatever
that could be generated artificially
that a human mind couldn't grasp even
after they had been generated
I don't think that's going to be true I
maybe this is a lack of imagination on
my part very very possible I could have
my priors you know my credences
dramatically changed but I think that
anything out there that is
understandable is understandable by
human beings I think there's a sort of
threshold of cognitive ability that you
can understand statements within the
worlds of logic and math and physics and
Science and so forth and we human beings
can do it might be hard
some statements in physics as we
understand it now are harder to
understand than others but I don't think
that there's any
true limitation to human beings ability
in that direction
the other question though is the ability
to come up with some with such
statements uh I'm a hundred percent
uh of the belief that artificial
thinking machines could might be able to
come up with statements which we human
beings didn't I don't think that the
current
generation of very impressive large
language models are trying to do are are
going to do that in fact I played with
them quite a bit precisely wondering
about this question can you use large
language models you know gpt4 or
whatever to answer difficult questions
no you can't you can't difficult
questions that have not yet been
answered by human beings because all
they do is take what human beings have
done and use that to make a predictive
language model right so if you try to
trick it by like giving it the Sleeping
Beauty problem or something it knows the
Sleeping Beauty problem is read about it
on the internet so it just gives you the
answers and it'll say well we're not
sure about what the answer is okay it's
very hard to get truly new insight from
a large language model but that's not to
say the different kinds of computer
intelligence couldn't do it so yeah that
I'm very excited about the possibility
that there are kinds of thinking and
kinds of conclusions that can be reached
by AI in the years to come
Anthony Robo says we are a mere four
years away from the 100th anniversary of
the fifth Solvay conference what do you
feel would be a particularly special way
in which the world's community of
scientists and thinkers could
commemorate such an amazing event
well that's a great question I'll tell
you why it's a great question I mean
there's a sort of down-to-earth aspect
of it which is like how do you
commemorate a big event okay and I'm not
going to go into too much about that but
here's the thing
the reason why we cared so much about
the fifth Solvay conference is because
we more or less cohered on an
understanding of quantum mechanics the
understanding we currently call The
Copenhagen interpretation right it was
truly focused on what we would Now call
the foundations of quantum mechanics
that's what everyone cared about
Einstein and Bohr and Schrodinger and
Heisenberg and Paulie and all those
folks who were there
and that's that at the time in 1927 that
was the Forefront of physics the most
exciting topic very few of the people
who you would recognize today as the
world's most famous leading physicists
think that the foundations of quantum
mechanics is a Forefront topic that we
should be spending a lot of time on I
think that and a few of my friends think
that so if you're a common listener to
mindscape you might get a distorted idea
but it's not a very uh High Prestige
subfield within physics as it is
currently understood so what I would
guess slash predict slash worry about is
that if you try to do a you know Century
later Solvay conference where we got the
brightest Minds in physics to talk about
the most interesting topics they would
talk about their current interests
whatever they were working on right
whether it was in string theory or
whatever you know they were working on
and they would get some good talks and
they'd be you know interesting things
but it wouldn't be anything like the
Solvay conference number one because
it's not about the foundations of
quantum mechanics so it wouldn't really
be in the spirit of that but number two
we don't have that consensus on what the
interesting questions are right now
right the reason why solve it was so
interesting is because everyone was
focused on the same issues and a lot of
the work a lot of the progress was made
not during the talks but at breakfast
and at drinks afterwards beer Belgian
ale was consumed in great quantities and
you cared about the same issues right
you had this common purpose
and so you could try to commemorate the
Solvay conference by bringing together
people who had some kind of common
purpose about something maybe it is the
foundations of quantum mechanics but
those people talk to each other a lot
already it's not a it's not a moment
even though I care about the foundations
of quantum mechanics I'm not going to
pretend that we are on the cusp of a
breakthrough or even the cusp of
bringing together a lot of disparate
ideas to form some consensus right so
that's what you would want that's the
kind of science you would want to really
do justice to the spirit of the fifth
solve a conference I'm a little
skeptical that's ever going to happen
probably a bunch of old farts just
patting each other on the back that's
what's probably going to happen
nalita s says when observing the
universe and its components it seems
that its interior goes through an
inevitable increase in entropy over time
second law of thermodynamics
and incorporating the mind-boggling
cosmological Multiverse idea into this
leads one to wonder if our universe
itself undergoes as a whole an increase
in entropy over time and how would the
expansion of the universe affect this
process
well there you have to sort of divide
this question
um into two different things one is the
Multiverse aspect and the other is the
expansion of the universe aspect these
are two different aspects so if you just
think about our observable universe so
put aside the Multiverse for a moment
think about the universe we live in and
the universe we see
it is increasing in entropy as a whole
yes and in fact one of my favorite
papers that I ever wrote that doesn't
get nearly as much attention as I would
like it to because it gets a result that
everyone expected was true already uh
was my paper with Aiden Chapman Davis
when he was a grad student at Caltech
and we showed that you could think of
the cosmic no hair theorem as the second
law of Thermodynamics so the cosmic no
hair theorem was first proven in some
cases by Bob Wald back in the 1980s and
it says that analogous to the black hole
no hair theorems that say that if you
make a black hole and you know it's all
lumpy and things those lumps kind of
quickly shake away and you settle down
to a black hole having no hair in the
presence of a cosmological constant the
universe does the same thing this is
wald's point that everything empties out
to all the galaxies and so forth smooth
out and it gets scattered to the Four
Winds and you're left with an empty
Universe with a cosmological constant
what we call decider space and a
universe that has no hair all such
universes are going to look the same
once you tell me the value of the
cosmological constant
that always sounded to me like
equilibration and thermalization or
whatever I want to call it so Aiden and
I proved a theorem that you could think
about I mean it's a very very minor
theorem under very very oversimplified
assumptions but there you could do
better hopefully
um
if you don't say anything about
Einstein's equation or general
relativity but instead you say the
universe increases in entropy up to a
maximum value and then stays constant we
borrowed a definition of entropy and
expand the universe from two former
mindscape guests Neda engelhardt and
Raphael buso and we showed that that
simple conjecture that the Universe
expands in entropy not in space time but
expands an entropy and then goes to a
constant that also implies that our
future space-time metric is to sitter
space just like general relativity says
so you can think of that approach to the
sitter space as equilibration and
increase in entropy it all makes sense
but that's only like one little part of
the universe right outside the universe
we observe lots of things could be
happening I am in favor or I like the
idea that I've I've published about
which says that there is a Multiverse
and at any one moment time with very
very large probability there is a
direction in time in which the
multiverses entropy is increasing even
if individual parts of the Multiverse
settle down to constant entropy to
sitter space you make more and more
universe and therefore you make more and
more entropy maybe even making more and
more universes by making baby universes
and if you trace backward far enough the
same thing is happening but in the other
direction of times there's some moment
where entropy is its minimum value but
that value could be very very large and
both before and after that moment
entropy increases as you go away from
that moment but we don't know that's a
conjecture that's a scenario a model
whatever you want to call it we don't
understand that the very very Ultra
large scale structure of the universe to
really say with any confidence
tarun says I'm currently reading your
biggest Ideas Book and particularly
enjoy the parts where you stop to
consider the philosophical implications
at one point you question whether
Newton's formulation of classical
mechanics or the principle of least
action is correct in terms of telling us
what nature is doing you propose that
neither is correct as nature is just
nature and does what it does but unless
I'm mistaken you appear to be more in
the camp that believes physics tells us
something deep about reality rather than
it being purely about building models
and should not be taken literally why do
you view this local versus global aspect
of physics differently to how you view
Quantum field theory for example
well it's possible I wasn't clear what I
was trying to say in that section of the
book I do believe that physics tells us
something deep about reality the point I
was trying to make there when I'm we're
discussing Newton's formulation of
classical mechanics versus the principle
of least action is that these are not
two different versions of reality it's
the same reality that is being described
either way so there's no argument about
whether which one is truly right or
truly wrong they're mathematically
equivalent to each other they're
different languages or different
vocabularies for talking about the same
underlying thing so to say well I think
that someday we'll discover that the
principle of least action is correct and
Newton's formulation is incorrect that
can never happen because you can derive
one from the other
thinking about nature in different ways
can be very helpful because we don't
know the fundamental laws of physics and
thinking about them one way or the other
might help us propose new ones but we're
not looking for just the right one once
and for all forever
Nick Gall says in your paper why
boltzmann brains are bad you base your
argument against boltzmann brains on
cognitive instability and you cite David
alber's book time and chance in support
I couldn't find any direct mention of
cognitive instability in Albert's book
but he gives another reason for
embracing the past hypothesis namely
that such an axiom is immensely fruitful
quote our ground grounds have to do with
the fact that the proposition that the
Universe came into being in an
enormously low entropy macro condition
turns out to be enormously helpful in
making an enormous variety of particular
empirical predictions
so my question is instead of dismissing
Bolton brains and other possibilities
invoking random fluctuations based on
cognitive instability why not base it on
the fruitfulness of the past Axiom
instead since the concept of
fruitfulness better matches the criteria
of theory Choice as discussed by
and others so this is a good point and
it's a slightly subtle thing let me see
if I can uh
answer it accurately it is true I've
actually talked with David about this
because
um I absolutely got the phrase cognitive
instability from David Albert and the
book that he wrote about entropying the
arrow of time is time and chance but as
we realized in talking to each other he
never actually uses that exact phrase in
the book he uses equivalent phrases he
talks about skeptical scenarios and
therefore
self-undermining scenarios so
self-undermining is uh kind of the same
thing or or there's different ways of
characterizing the same idea the point
is you cannot consistently both hold a
belief and have good reasons for holding
the belief in these scenarios at the
same time so I misattributed the phrase
uh but it is his phrase so I didn't do
too badly I didn't steal the phrase from
someone else
the more important question here is is
it the right phrase the right idea to be
pointing at or should we point to
fruitfulness instead and again these are
two little things that are closely
related but not exactly the same that
are worth saying one is that the the
slightly different questions being asked
here
um when I'm talking about boltzmann
brains I'm basically
contrasting the idea that we are a
random fluctuation with the idea that we
are not a random fluctuation so any
other scenario other than us being
boltzman brains is being contemplated
here and in the particular case of
boltzmann brains
um it is cognitively unstable but the
set of large set of alternatives
it would be hard to characterize them as
fruitful because there's a lot of
different Alternatives right when we're
talking about the past hypothesis and
here this is the other point that's a
very specific alternative and as as
David correctly says it is immensely
fruitful but by itself I don't think
that that gives us license to accept it
if we were believing that there was if
we had a high prior Credence on randomly
fluctuating universes precisely because
if the universe were randomly
fluctuating
there would be you know and you
conditionalized on finding observers who
thought that there was a past hypothesis
and thought that it was fruitful to
think so in a randomly fluctuating
Universe the overwhelming majority of
such Universe of such observers are
totally wrong
so it doesn't help you right it doesn't
actually get you out of the Dilemma
you're trying to get in you can't just
say it's fruitful to imagine there's a
past hypothesis you have to give a
positive reason for rejecting the random
fluctuation scenario and so I think that
just the fact that it it
if you believed that that scenario had a
possibility of being true it would
prevent you from doing anything else you
uh cannot possibly move forward using
logic and reason and evidence if you
think that that scenario might be the
universe in which you live so I think we
should we should reject it whatever
label you want to put on that rejection
Elijah Frisch asks another priority
question hypothetically if some future
evidence or Discovery helped prove that
everybody in interpretation is correct
what do you think that Discovery could
look like conversely in theory what type
of Discovery or evidence might persuade
an everetteian toward a different
interpretation of quantum mechanics well
um there's sort of a fanciful answer to
this and a more realistic answer the
fanciful answer is you know if you could
talk to other universes or if you could
detect them in some way that would be a
discovery that helps you do it of course
by the actual
mechanics of everetting quantum
mechanics that is so incredibly unlikely
to happen that even if it did you would
probably say it's probably something
else right you probably wouldn't believe
it even if you saw it so I'm not waiting
around for that to happen but I've said
this before I'll just say it again when
you say the words I've read in quantum
mechanics what do you mean you mean that
you say that reality is modeled by a
wave function or a Quantum state or a
state Vector in hilber space however you
want to say it and the only thing that
wave function ever does is obey the
Schrodinger equation okay that's the
entirety of the Everett interpretation
it's it's fundamental formulation so
there's a lot of evidence and it's
correct all the evidence we have that
there are wave functions that they away
the Schrodinger equation all all that
evidence counts as evidence for the
average interpretation what you want to
do is compare it to alternatives
okay and so if you have an alternative
you have to ask
how does that alternative differ from
Everett so back when we were talking
about the density matrices and
decoherence if you literally have a
physical mechanism that gets rid of
other elements of the density Matrix
other than the ones you find yourself in
that's a difference in then to
everetting quantum mechanics and it's a
difference with potentially observable
consequences and I'm sorry that you know
I'm not I don't mean to be grumpy toward
you Elijah but I've made this point many
many many times there are theories where
the wave function clearly does not
always obey the Schrodinger equation
where it spontaneously collapses Roger
Penrose has such a theory okay we can
look for that and if we see it happening
ever it is wrong he is falsified and
everyone would be very happy
Carl popper himself got this he never
said that Everett was unfalsifiable he
didn't like it because he had his own
favorite interpretation of quantum
mechanics but he liked Everett a lot
more than he liked Copenhagen which he
thought was just philosophically
nonsensical
Fabian rostollen says
from what I understand you don't believe
that P zombies are possible is that
correct and in that case what is your
take on the question of moral
consideration of HEI artificial general
intelligence I can't think of any tests
that would indicate whether or not AGI
is really sentient or if it's just in a
hypothetical case where the AGI is
behaving as if it were sentient
well that's my point my point in saying
that P zombies are not possible is that
if you actually had a physical system
that behaved in every way exactly
identical to that as a conscious
creature would behave then it's
conscious
the tricky thing there is the every way
thing right you know how do you know
that your physical system behaves in
every way like a conscious creature does
rather than just in some ways that's why
we worry about the touring test or
whatever but my point uh about pea
zombies philosophical zombies is the
thing that is trying to be conceived is
a being that thinks it's conscious if
you talk to it and say are you conscious
it says yes if you say like are you
experiencing the redness of red it says
yes it will describe to you what that is
like we know that because it acts
exactly like a conscious creature does
but then you somehow imagine that it's
wrong that it's it's not lying to you
but it's it's sincerely misre informed
about its own inner mental States
and I don't think that that is a
plausible conception if it were this is
another self-underbinding argument going
on here if it were then you would have
to admit that our introspection about
our experiences is utterly unreliable
because a zombie thinks it's
introspecting about its inner
experiences and apparently you're saying
it's not getting the right answer so
that's not good evidence of anything
so I say the same thing about artificial
general intelligence that if it's doing
something if it's behaving in the same
way as a conscious creature then it's
conscious but the behavior is really not
just like getting up and walking it's
all the things going on in its brain
whatever that brain is it's the
Believers in P zombies who beg the
question by presuming that it's possible
to imagine something that has all the
behaviors of a conscious creature yet
doesn't have conscious experience which
is cheating
Simon Hayward says radioactive decay
occurs with a known Half-Life so the
number of events is easily predicted
however from the perspective of a given
atom the received wisdom seems to be
that this event is random is this
actually true or does the apparent
random nature reflects some missing
knowledge of the state of the individual
atoms well I think it's really true that
the statement in conventional quantum
mechanics is it's really true of course
there are some people who believe in
Hidden variable theories of quantum
mechanics and so they say there is some
missing knowledge there but they will
also say you it's not only missing
knowledge it is inaccessible knowledge
until you see the atom Decay or not
Decay you can't say whether it's going
to that that knowledge is inaccessible
to you that's a part of hidden variable
theories
Nikola Ivanov says is the mechanism
behind the unrew effect similar to
Hawking radiation both create black body
radiation a thermal bath the first due
to an observer's accelerating reference
frame in a vacuum and the second due to
the strong gravity field of black holes
yeah exactly that was unru's idea so for
those of you who don't know we have
Hawking radiation discovered by Stephen
Hawking or at least theoretically
predicted by Stephen Hawking in 1974 I
think
um near a black hole the quantum State
settles into a configuration where it is
giving off radiation okay you know
detector could detect it
unru Bill unru uh thought about the
space time around a black hole and he
realized that it was actually very
similar to a subset of the space-time in
flat space so in good old ordinary
minkowski space with no black holes no
gravity at all if you cut out a wedge
and look at just that wedge it has many
of the properties that
a black hole space time does I'm
realizing now this is not helpful to you
because it's a space time wedge and
you're going to be thinking of a spatial
wedge and you're going to get the wrong
impression there but if you have a space
time diagram with X going left right T
going up down light cones going in the
diagonal okay so take the wedge on the
right side of that figure so the
positive x-axis and values of time in
between plus and minus X so that whole
wedge to the right of the light cone the
light cone in the future is kind of like
a future Event Horizon the light cone in
the past is kind of like a past Event
Horizon and the whole thing is very much
like the space time outside a black hole
and then he realized that if you are an
accelerating Observer an observer that
accelerated at a constant acceleration
forever
you could stay inside that wedge forever
and to you it would be like that was the
whole space time in which you lived and
then he that's maybe you could imagine
hand waving your way into that
conclusion but Bill did the calculation
and what he showed is that it's a
feature of quantum field theory in flat
space time that an observer accelerating
at a constant acceleration sees a
thermal bath of particles even if they
are in the vacuum
this is just a sneaky feature of quantum
field theory in minkowski space has
nothing to do with gravity but it's very
similar to what gives rise to Black Hole
radiation so to Nicola's question is it
similar yes and that similarity is
entirely intentional
Craig Vandervest says in a previous AMA
you mentioned that Baltimore has good
restaurants what are a few of your
favorites
um
I think my single favorite is Alma Alma
Cucina Latina near the train station is
really good very inventive Cuisine you
know they'll give you
um
sort of South American dumplings like
but they're dumplings that look like
gyozas but they're South American and
they're very very tasty and a whole
bunch of sort of fun fusion Cuisine
things but Baltimore is especially good
at is sort of upscale casual things like
not super duper fancy Michelin star
restaurants but there is
um a French Bistro uh called duck duck
goose which I like very much the seafood
restaurants are amazing if you want just
the the whole fish recently caught from
nearby prepared you know in a very
non-intrusive way so you can really love
the fish but we're super good at that uh
the black olive or uzo or Mediterranean
restaurants that kind of do that
um and you know there's there's fancier
restaurants also there's
um the Charleston so is a famous fancy
restaurant nearby they're sort of an
American kind of modern restaurant
called Gunter and Co which I like a lot
but anyway there's a lot of restaurants
that are really really good but I should
give a shout out to Super Rihanna which
is very close to Hopkins which is a kind
of greekish restaurant but again kind of
casual Pub feel but a great place to
just hang out get some really good
Falafel or lamb or what have you
Josh Charles says If gravity is the
result of curved space-time why are
gravitons a thing
well because gravity being the result of
curved space-time is an entirely
classical statement that's what general
relativity tells you in general
relativity is a classical Theory
gravitons are what happened when you
quantize gravity and you can't we don't
have the once and for all full theory of
quantum gravity as I'm sure you've been
told but we have no problem looking at
weak field tiny variations in the
curvature of space-time and quantizing
them and what you get are gravitons I
mean you could exactly as well say if
electromagnetism is the result of the
electric field in the magnetic field why
are photons a thing it's the classical
Theory versus the quantum theory and the
quantum theory you quantize the field
and you see particles
Paul Conte says as a British European
follower of your podcast books Etc I
find it very difficult to understand the
American obsession with guns and
Firearms at the Second Amendment while I
appreciate the historical origin of the
Second Amendment like most Brits I am
utterly astounded the huge number of U.S
gun deaths every year whether deliberate
by accident or in suicides what is your
opinion of gun control and do you own
any guns yourself
so I'm sure it must look weird to the
outside world we've talked about guns a
couple times on the podcast Andrew Papa
Cristo's most obviously
um but it is true that the United States
is singular in its obsession with guns
and I think you know like many of these
things they're kind of a perfect storm
going on here the second amendment was
like many things well-intentioned you
know people were very worried at the
time the late 18th century in the
tyranny of the government and and the
government using its military might to
step in and taking freedoms away from
the populace you know the idea of
democracy and self-control and
self-representation and
self-determination were not taken for
granted back then so they wrote in one
of the and remember if you're European
or British maybe you don't know but we
had
After the Revolutionary War a government
called the uh the the articles of the
Confederates Confederation which tried
to just be a very
loosey-goosey Arrangement where the
individual states were the actual
centers of control and they got together
to talk things over under the
Confederation it didn't work states got
together and they disarged with each
other and it didn't form a whole
sensible country so there was a campaign
to get a constitution that would really
give us a strong federal government that
could organize the country not everyone
was on board right I mean that's one of
the things that made Alexander Hamilton
famous was contributing to the
Federalist Papers which tried to
convince people that this Constitution
which would really make us a whole
single country was a good idea and one
of the things that many people including
Thomas Jefferson and others argued is
that the constitution as written
just said what the government can do and
how the government works it didn't say
whether government can't do it didn't
have a Bill of Rights so the Bill of
Rights was put in later not that much
later it was part of the original
adoption but it was written after the
Constitution was drafted as an attempt
to lay out some of the rights and so in
the Second Amendment it says the idea of
a well-ordered militia
is very important because the people can
get together and resist a tyrannical
government so therefore the the right to
own arms the right to bear arms should
not be infringed
it's right there in the amendment that
the point of this is to have a
well-ordered militia but anyway what it
concludes is saying therefore the right
to bear arms should not be infringed
so take that as maybe a slight accident
of history and how the exact wording of
this amendment was drafted and now you
know there's political game theory that
goes on sure plenty of people in the
United States go hunting or whatever or
have a gun in their house for personal
protection but you could imagine being
allowed to do that without making a
whole thing out of it in the United
States we very much make it a thing it's
a part of your identity for some people
uh politicians running for office show
pictures of themselves at Christmas with
their family where every member of the
family is holding a gun and that's just
bizarre and a little weird but it's part
of
signaling that you're a member of a
certain tribe and the Liberals are never
going to take away my guns and there's a
positive feedback loop that gets more
and more guns out there
so I don't own any guns myself I am not
you know
um afraid of guns or think that they
could be a bad thing I think that or
think they necessarily are always bad
and should be banned and eliminated but
certainly they should be controlled and
regulated at least as much as a car
should be it's much easier to get a gun
in the United States than it is a
driver's license and that's just wacky
and weird by the way it's also much
easier to become a police officer than
it is to get many other jobs in the
United States the amount of training and
prerequisites for being a police officer
in the US are very low
and we see the impacts of that right so
I don't own any guns myself but again I
could imagine owning a gun I don't have
any special desire to do so I don't
think it's evil but certainly there
should be not only background checks but
you should have to pass some kind of
exam just like you do for driving and
right now you don't right now it's not
like that and there are so many guns out
there uh that it's going to be difficult
to lower the amount of guns that we have
in the United States and to bring them
under some kind of control
Peter blankenheim says Yang Mills theory
is such an important Cornerstone of all
modern physics for those of us who have
a rough understanding of tensor algebra
could you briefly encapsulate what is
conceptually at the core of this
algebraic truth and why it is so
important specifically how it can unite
the weak nuclear and the electric fields
well I won't go into great detail here
because I'm writing a book on it
yangville's theory is going to be part
it's going to be one of the chapters in
uh quanta and Fields the second
volume in the biggest ideas in the
universe and of course that means that
you can find the video right I did a
whole video on Symmetry and gauge theory
in fact maybe two different
videos one on symmetry one on gauge
Theory one on topology and geometry
which is also important but if you go
through these videos you will be uh
introduced to the basics of Yang Mills
theory for those of you who don't know
or don't want to watch the videos
yangmil's theory is a generalization of
electromagnetism so electromagnetism e m
is as we discovered after the theory was
invented it can be thought of as arising
from a certain symmetry you can think of
a Charged particle like an electron it
has a wave function right and that wave
function is a complex number
and it can be rotated you can rotate a
complex number a complex number is a
plus IB where A and B are real numbers I
is the square root of minus one so you
can rotate a little Vector in the
complex plane and there's no physical
effect of that happening what happens in
electromagnetism is you can do that
rotation separately at every point in
space time so basically there's an
arbitrary choice at every point in space
time as to what you call the real part
of the electron and what you call the
imaginary part of the electron you need
both but which is which doesn't matter
in fact you can make it two-thirds this
and one-third that Etc okay and you can
do that separately at every point in
space time how do you know
how to compare an electron at one point
in space-time and another point in space
time you need what is called a
connection you need one way to transport
the value of the electron field at one
point over to the other points you can
compare them so you can say are they the
same charge or opposite charge or
whatever
that connection that that information in
between the two points in space time is
a field
and that field gives rise to the the
electric and magnetic field it's called
the gauge field and it gives rise to
both electric and magnetic fields by
just taking derivatives of them anyway
this might be over the heads of some of
the listeners but we're getting near the
end of this long podcast so that's okay
what Yang Mill's Theory does is it just
generalizes that so instead of saying
there's an electron and it has a wave
function or a field that has a real part
in an imaginary part you say there are
quarks and quarks can be red green or
blue right three different colors so
really by the way they don't tell you
this but it's not true that quarks can
be red green or blue what the truth is
that quarks are a vector in a
three-dimensional color space
red green and blue are fanciful names
for the axes of three-dimensional color
space there's the red axis the green X's
the blue x's and a quark is just a
vector pointing in any direction in that
three-dimensional space
but what you call Red what do you call
the red Direction
what you call the green Direction what
you call the blue direction is
completely arbitrary you can rotate your
bases
basis vectors and that's exactly and now
you're just going down the same story if
you have two quarks or two different
positions how do you compare them well
you need a connection field in between
that tells you how to compare them that
connection gives rise to a force field
which in the case of quantum
chromodynamics is the gluon in the case
of the weak nuclear force it's the w and
z bosons Etc so basically Yang Mills
Theory I know this is probably
incomprehensible to anyone because it's
too short but I encourage you to watch
the longer video if it's not or buy the
book when it comes out next year
um the short version is there is a
symmetry because nobody cares what you
call Red what you call Green what you
call Blue but the way to both have that
Symmetry and nevertheless let yourself
compare what's going on at different
points in space time requires the
existence of a new field which acts like
a force field that we call a gauge field
that gives an interaction between the
different particles in the standard
model
okay I think I'm becoming less coherent
at the end of this long day but that's
okay we're near the end two more
questions left one is from Ash right are
there any subjects for which your
thinking has evolved enough in the past
few years the readers of your books or
listeners to early podcasts might want
to take in with an extra grain of salt
you know my my sub my opinions change
over time I just mentioned uh the
Insight I got from Ed Watts's podcast on
the fall of the Roman Republic but
I don't think that you should be taking
any prior podcasts with grains of salt
um
because it's the process it's the
journey not the destination trust the
process as I will say again in a few
seconds
you know I think you can learn things
from any of the previous episodes very
often in previous episodes I have people
on who I don't agree with about things
but I will always try to have people on
who I think it is useful and productive
to talk to whether I agree with them or
not and almost always I think I succeed
in doing that so I don't think it's
about grains of salt I think it's about
you should always have a grain of salt
when you're listening to anyone
podcasting about anything listen to what
they say and ask how well it fits with
other things you know what questions you
have about it uh how much of it sounds
trustworthy Etc
and finally Attila bartha asks do you
think the 76ers have a chance to beat
the Boston Celtics without Joelle embiid
so background for those of you who are
not NBA basketball fans it's the last
question of the podcast of the AMA I can
I can talk about whatever I want so
I'm a huge basketball fan NBA fan and my
team ever since I was a Youngster is the
Philadelphia 76ers and this year the
76ers are very good
another team that is very good is the
Boston Celtics and these two teams have
been historic Rivals I just saw the um
statistic uh recently that the Sixers
and Celtics have played each other 22
times in the NBA Playoffs which is the
most of any two teams in the NBA in fact
the next most is only 14 times for the
next most uh frequent pairing in the NBA
playoffs going back to Will Chamberlain
versus Bill Russell
Julius Erving versus Larry Bird Alan
Iverson versus Paul Pierce and now we
have Joel embiid versus Jason Tatum and
other there's other very good basketball
players on both teams in fact I'm
recording this on Wednesday May 3rd uh
just last night we learned that Joel
embiid
um was awarded the most valuable player
award the MVP award for the NBA which I
think is well deserved and it's very
cute you can see videos online and you
know he's been he literally embiid was
literally in second place for the MVP
award two years prior to this so he's
been so close without getting it and you
know he knew it was coming everyone who
votes for the MVP tends to Spill the
Beans ahead of time what their vote is
and many of them had said they were
voting for embiid so we kind of knew it
was happening and he still broke down
and cried when the news came out uh
embiid has been through a lot he
discovered basketball late you know he
was born and raised and grew up in
Cameroon
he didn't pick up a basketball or hear
about until he's 15 years old a lot of
the kids in the United States start
playing basketball when they're five
years old and are trained ever since so
he was very bad but he was very tall and
very athletic he was a volleyball player
and a soccer player so he got recruited
um and then he got injured he missed not
just the first year but the first two
years of his NBA career and while he was
sitting on the sidelines not playing
because of injury his younger brother
Arthur back in Cameroon was killed in a
car crash and he came very close and B
came very close to just quitting
basketball and never playing and he did
start playing and is very very good one
of the best players in the NBA and yet
he has been subject to like bizarrely
unpredictable injury luck
um his own teammate
his face with his teammate's shoulder
and he cracked his face and had to wear
a mask one year in the playoffs just
last year a some player on the other
team hit him in the face again and gave
him a concussion and again heard his
skull and he came back but didn't play
very well this year he sprained his knee
in the first round of the playoffs and
so my update here Wednesday May 3rd is
the 76ers played the Celtics in their
playoff game on Monday and they won they
won in Boston without embiid in just one
of the most entertaining basketball
games I've ever watched tonight is game
two and embiid just proclaimed that he's
gonna play he's well enough again to
play I sincerely hope that he is well
enough to play I don't want him to hurt
himself again I would rather not win any
more games than have him hurt himself
again and rather keep him healthy for
the future and for his own future but
we'll see I mean the medical staff and
the coaching staff wouldn't let him play
if they didn't think that he could run
and jump and generally be healthy so
fingers crossed on that but by the time
you hear this in between when I record
it and when you hear it there will be at
least more bask two more basketball
games played between the Sixers and the
Celtics uh
no wait three more it's Wednesday so
there's Wednesday Friday and Sunday so
there's three more so the series might
be over if the Sixers win all their
games that's unlikely I like pretend
that it's likely because I'm a I'm a fan
more than I am an analyst of basketball
games but
um or we could be down 3-1 we could be
on the brink of elimination you never
know that's why sports are so one of the
reasons why sports are so much fun
because it is literally not predictable
ahead of time so to the actual question
Attila do the Sixers have a chance to
beat the Celtics without a mead the
answer is always yes just like when
people ask physics questions is it
possible that the answer is always yes
it is possible the answer is always yes
a good NBA team has a chance to beat
another good NBA team they just did it
on Monday
with embiid
they'll play much better defense and
they have an even better chance of
winning it's still possible the Celtics
have a chance to win all the rest of the
games there's always a chance I just
want to enjoy it I want to have fun the
Sixers have a great
chance this year uh to win if you
literally as of this moment when I'm
talking if you go to 538.com and look at
their
odds for winning the NBA title the
Sixers had the largest odds of any team
right now
still not greater than 50 though and you
know things can happen freak injuries
could still happen it's unpredictable
let's enjoy the journey let's enjoy the
ride let's trust the process go Sixers
I'll be back a month from now and if if
the Sixers are in the finals a month
from now I might just do a much shorter
Ama or I might just do a holy basketball
focused AMA who knows we'll find out
then thanks for listening bye-bye
thank you
[Music]